GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
APRIL EIGHTEENTH. WHO RULED
THROUGH ONE TWENTY SIX?
CALLING FOR MEMBERS OF THIS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE IN
ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX SERGEANTS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELCOME TO OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING. JUST A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
RULES.
FIRST MISTER SPEAKER HAS
APPOINTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK
STONE TO FILL IN THE DEMOCRATIC
VACANCY FOR TODAY'S HEARING
ONLY.
WE HAVE TWELVE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY.
ONE OF THOSE IS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT.
ITEM THIRTEEN WHICH IS A B.
THIRTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN
RODRIGUEZ.
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ONCE WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY ONE TRAVIS
ALLEN.
IT'S OFF THE CALENDAR ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT.
ALSO.
WE ONLY HAVE THIS ROOM UNTIL
FOUR PM TODAY SO I'M GOING TO
ASK OUR AUTHORS.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO KEEP THIS
TIME LIMITED IN MIND SO THAT WE
CAN ALLOW ENOUGH REVIEW FOR
ENTIRE AGENDA.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
HERE'S BILLS AND SIGN IN ORDER.
AND WE WILL START AS A SUB
OPERATE IS A SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY
UNTIL WE GET A QUORUM.
OUR FIRST BILL THIS AFTERNOON.
IS ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
TWO CHIU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU IN
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
.
IT.
MR CHIU IN I OR JOINT AUTHORS
HE'S IN THE LEAD.
AND HE HAS ASKED IF HE WANTS TO
PRESENT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY BUT ALL I CAN
CERTAINLY TALK ABOUT THE BILL.
IF YOU'D LIKE ME TO BUT TO I
WANT TO GIVE HIM THAT.
OKAY SASS FOR THE HE'S ASKED FOR
THAT OPPORTUNITY.
WELL I'M KIND MINUTES QUANDARY
WE HAVE THREE CHIU BILLS RIGHT
NOW ROW.
IS.
WE COULD MOVE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUICKSILVER IS SHE HERE.
NO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHEN.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A SHORT
PAUSE.
FOR A COMMERCIAL I'M IN A
QUANDARY I'M IN A QUANDARY AS
WELL BECAUSE.
IS HE HE SPECIFICALLY ACT PASSED
I UNDERSTAND.
THANK YOU
.
COULD I ASK TO TAKE THE
SPREADING OVER.
MILLION LAY BACK AND WAIT. FOR
DAVID CHIU.
MEMBERS IS CLOSE BY.
VARIOUS.
MR CHOOSE HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ZERO ITEM THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO.
WELCOME IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR HER.
THAT I KNOW THAT EVERY MEMBER
IN THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS THAT IN
OUR STATE WE ARE EXPERIENCING
NOT JUST THE WORST HOUSING
CRISIS. IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY
BUT HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
ONE THAT WE SEE WITH HEPATITIS A
ANY COLI OUTBREAKS TENT
ENCAMPMENTS OF THE DEVASTATION
CAUSED BY FIRE MUDSLIDES.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST HOMELESSNESS
RATE IN THE COUNTRY TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF AMERICANS WHO ARE
HOMELESS LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
FORTY TWO PERCENT OF AMERICA'S
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS ARE IN OUR
STATE. WE'VE ALSO SEEN THE
HIGHEST RECENT INCREASES AND
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A BILL TO MOVE FOR
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
WHICH IS HOUSING THAT IS PAIRED
WITH SERVICES
A PROVEN METHOD OF REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MEANS. THAT WE'VE SEEN FROM A
POLICY STANDPOINT TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS.
WE'VE HEARD FROM DEVELOPERS THAT
BUILT PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
THAT IT OFTEN MAY TAKE THREE
YEARS TO BUILD BECAUSE OF LOCAL
APPROVAL PROCESS HE'S.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO STREAMLINE THE
APPROVAL OF A HUNDRED PERCENT
AFFORDABLE DEVELOPMENTS THAT
INCLUDE A MINIMUM PERCENTAGE OF
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS. ARMED
SERVICES WOULD NEED TO BE
PROVIDED ON SITE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
APPLY OBJECTIVE AND QUANTIFIABLE
DESIGN STANDARDS. ONE AT THIS
POINT TURN IT OVER TO MY JOINT
AUTHORS MR DAILY REPRESENTING
THE DISTRICT THAT HAS HAS.
AS INTENSE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
AS WE'VE SEEN AROUND THE STATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU. YES SIR
IN MY HOME COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY
THE DEBATE OVER HOW AND WHERE TO
HOUSE THE HOMELESS IS REACHED
THE COURTS PROMPTING A FEDERAL
JUDGE TO INTERVENE.
AND OVERSEE POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS.
RESEARCHERS AT UC IRVINE.
IN MY HOME COUNTY. HAVE FOUND
THAT THE AVERAGE ANNUAL COST OF
SERVICES FOR THE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS DECLINED. WHEN THEY ARE
PLACED IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
TO THAT END.
THE CITY OF SANTA ANA THE COUNTY
SEAT.
IN ORANGE COUNTY RECENTLY
APPROVED A LARGE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROJECT.
THIS IS ALL IN MY DISTRICT.
A DEVELOPER CONVERTED IN OLD
MOTEL INTO A SEVENTY TWO UNIT.
COMMUNITY DEDICATED TO
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
AND SMALL FAMILIES.
THERE'S A NON PROFIT INVOLVED
MERCY HOUSE WHICH PROVIDE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR THE
RESIDENTS.
THIS BILL.
.
WILL HELP PROMOTE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF MORE SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING PROJECTS LIKE THIS ONE.
IN AREAS WHERE CITIES ALREADY
PLAN FOR AND ALLOW MULTI FAMILY
DEVELOPMENT.
THE BILL EXPEDITES THE TIMELINE
FOR APPROVAL OF OF THESE
PROJECTS.
WHICH WILL HELP LOWER THE COST
OF BUILDING AND THEREBY
INCENTIVIZE OTHERS.
TO CONSTRUCT SUCH SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE PROJECTS.
WILL BE CONSISTENT WITH LOCAL
ZONING BUT THIS IS ONE MORE TOOL
TO ENABLE THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE.
TO.
TO ACHIEVE THAT END.
SO I RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE SO. WHEN WE GET TO THAT
POINT.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU
DON'T MIND WE'RE GOING TO DO A
LITTLE BIT OF HOUSEKEEPING
BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD.
.
DIXIE WHICH PLEASE ESTABLISH
QUORUM.
ADWARE CURRY THEIR AGUIAR CURRY
HERE WALDRON BLOOM CABALLERO
COOLEY GRAYSON.
GRAYSON HERE LACKEY. LACKEY HERE
STONE.
STONE HERE VOEPEL. VOEPEL HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WILL MOVEON YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE OF WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT LIKE TO TURN OVER TO
OUR SPONSORS.
I AM DIANE WITH TERM ADVOCACY
MENTOR FOR EA EIGHT HOUSING.
WE ARE A NONPROFIT DEVELOPER
WE'VE BEEN AROUND FOR FIFTY
YEARS NOW THIS YEAR.
A WE HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TEN PROPERTIES ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND IN HAWAII.
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT OF THOSE
PROPERTIES HAVE UNITS THAT ARE
SET ASIDE FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IN OTHER WORDS
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
THAT THIS BILL. EYES TRYING TO
ENABLE.
WE HAVE FOUR MORE THAT ARE IN
THE PIPELINE.
SOME OF OUR PROJECTS HAVE.
A PORTION OF THEM THAT ARE
PERMITS PART OF HOUSING AND SOME
ARE A HUNDRED PERCENT.
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AN EXAMPLE IS THE POINT ON
VERMONT.
IN LOS ANGELES
A PROJECT THAT IS NOW IN THE
PIPELINE THAT WHERE THE
DEVELOPERS FOR NOW BE HUNDRED
PERCENT PSH.
THAT PROJECT WILL MOVE ALONG
WELL BECAUSE LOS ANGELES HAS
ADOPTED STREAMLINING FOR OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND WE FIGURED THAT THAT'LL SAVE
US PROBABLY ONE TO TWO YEARS.
ON THAT PROJECT.
WHENEVER WE ARE LOOKING AT A
POTENTIAL SITE FOR. PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OF COURSE WE
LOOK AT. AMENITIES SERVICES
LOCATION THINGS LIKE THAT A BUT
WE ALSO LOOK AT WHAT IS THE
LOCAL SUPPORT AND AND POSSIBLE
OPPOSITION TO THE PROJECT AND.
IF WE DO SEE THAT NEIGHBORS ARE.
REALLY OPPOSED IN REALLY WELL
ORGANIZED AND SOMETIMES WILL
BACK OFF AND NOT DO THE PROJECT
AT ALL.
BUT MORE TYPICALLY WILL STICK
WITH IT.
AND.
IT'LL COST US ANOTHER YEAR OR
TWO OF THE PROJECT WHICH MAKES
THE PROJECT MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE.
IT'S
LESS EFFICIENT IN TERMS OF USING
THE PROPER TAXPAYERS DOLLARS AND
ALSO AT LEAST PEOPLE ON THE
STREETS LAWYER.
SO.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO WOULD
HELP US IN SEVERAL WAYS WHO
WOULD MAKE THE PROJECTS MORE
FEASIBLE AND MORE PREDICTABLE.
IT WOULD MAKE MORE SITES
AVAILABLE TO US FOR THAT PURPOSE
AND.
WOULD BE MAKE PROJECTS MORE
COST EFFECTIVE.
BY ELIMINATING WHAT WE CALL
ENTITLEMENT RISK.
WE KNOW THAT WE CAN TALK TO
LENDERS AND INVESTORS AND
THEY'LL COME ON BOARD SOONER AND
WITH MORE MONEY.
BECAUSE THEY'RE SURE THAT THE
PROJECT WILL.
GO FORWARD.
SO IF WE HAVE THIS IN PLACE
THEN WE CAN USE LOCAL FUNDS WE
CAN USE THE UPCOMING STATE PHONE
FUNDS. WE CAN USE NO PLACE LIKE
HOME FUNDS THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY GOING TO PSH.
WE CAN ALL STEP UP AND AND GET
IT DONE A A LOT FASTER.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MEET THEIR RENO
OBLIGATIONS.
TO CLEAN UP THEIR STREETS AND
ALSO IT WOULD FREE LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS FROM HAVING TO TAKE
DIFFICULT. VOTES AND TAKE
POLITICAL RISK BY SUPPORTING AND
THESE PROJECTS SO.
AS A NONPROFIT THAT'S IN THE
TRENCHES OF TRYING TO GET THESE
ARE HOUSING THIS HOUSING BUILT.
I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO OUR HOUSING
CHAMPIONS HERE. AT THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO YOU ALL FOR
DOING THE WORK THAT HELPS US.
GET THIS WORK DONE.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTION THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT
OF HOUSING WHERE ONE OF THE
BILL'S CO SPONSORS.
AND WE KNOW TWENTY FIVE YEARS
PLUS WORTH OF DATA SHOW
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING NOT ONLY.
IMPROVES HOUSING AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES IT ALSO REDUCES OF
LOCAL AND STATE COSTS FOR HEALTH
CORRECTIONS CHILD WELFARE.
SYSTEMS DATA ALSO SHOW
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IMPROVES
PROPERTY VALUES AND REDUCES
BLIGHT IN THE COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH IT'S SPELLED.
YEAH IT'S INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
TO BUILD TO A REQUIRES OVER TEN
SOURCES OF FUNDING ON AVERAGE
AND TO BE COMPETITIVE FOR
FUNDING. WE KNOW SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING HAS TO BE GREENER HOUSES
SERVE THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND IT HAS TO GET
COMMUNITY SUPPORT.
.
AB TWO TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO
WOULD ALLOW SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
PROVIDERS TO RECEIVE MY RIGHT
APPROVAL WHICH WILL SPECIFICALLY
WHICH WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS AND AS MS
LUTHER. SAID WOULD BE CHEAPER TO
BUILD.
THE BILL WILL ALSO ENSURE THAT
DEVELOPMENTS WILL BILL BILL BE
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS AND
STANDARDS FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING.
AND.
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH STATE FUNDING IN
THE PAST AND GOING OUT SLOWLY.
IT WOULD ENSURE IN FACT THAT
FUNDING WILL BE USED TO AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE HOUSE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS. AND OTHER
VULNERABILITIES.
WE ARE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
DAILY IN SHOE FOR AND AUTHORING
THIS CRITICAL LEGISLATION AND WE
URGE YOUR I'VE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF PLEASE
JOIN US AT THE MICROPHONE NAME
ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION ONLY
THANK YOU.
THE MAN CHAIRMAN CHIEF DONE HERE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND THINKING THE
OFFICE FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE.
TYRONE BUCKLEY WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA REALLY PROUD AND A CO
SPONSOR THIS AND HER DRIVER.
MARINO I WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT.
MADISON Y. ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
WEST SAM'S ON BEHALF UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ANGELIQUE WORK WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SUPPORT.
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
YEAH GEORGE REPRESENTING
AND.
WE'VE SUBMITTED A LOT OF
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ACCEPTED BY THE SPONSORS
AND THE AUTHORS AND WE WORKED
WELL WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF WE
APPRECIATE THAT.
WERE DOWN TO THE PROCESSING
TIME LINE AND I THINK WE HAVE A.
OF COMPROMISE THAT GIVES A
SHORTER PERIOD OF TIME FOR THOSE
SMALLER PROJECTS AND A LITTLE
BIT LONGER FOR OF THOSE PROJECTS
THAT ARE SO VERY LARGE A
CUMBERSOME SO. WE HOPE WE GET TO
SCHOOL SUPPORT.
MICHAEL LANE WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION ON A
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT SING NINE
ANYONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE. IN IT ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY AYE A ONE IN A TIME. WHEN
WE ARE MOVING BILL OKAY. SO
REMEMBER GRACE SIN THEN WHO DID
THE SECOND.
SECOND ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
OKAY I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
NAY MANAGER APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
AND LET ME JUST SAY WITH
REGARDS TO APA'S AMENDMENTS I
THINK WORK.
ALMOST THERE WITHOUT THE
TECHNICAL FINE DETAILS AND
HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO GET
THERE WITH THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
BUT AT THIS TIME AS A STATE
WERE FINALLY STARTING TO INVEST
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT ARE
SEVERE AND CURRENT HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS MEANS WE NEED THESE UNITS
REBUILT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
THIS BILL WILL HELP TO PROVIDE
CERTAINTY THAT THAT HAPPENS.
WITH THAT ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND TURN IT OVER TO MISTER DALY.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
POSITIVE RECOMMENDATION AND ALL
BE WORKING WITH MISTER CHU HUA
ON THE REFINEMENTS THAT THAT HE
MENTIONED AND.
.
WE WILL APPRECIATE YOUR
POSITIVE VOTE THANK YOU.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE THEY'RE GONNA TRY TO
GET THAT. LITTLE THINGS CLEANED
UP SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU MOVING THIS FORWARD.
OKAY.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND MAY
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR CURRY I'M
AGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON. BLOOM
CABALLERO.
WHO COOLEY?
COOLEY AYE. GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO.
CABALLERO AYE.
LET'S OUTSIDE TO TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THREE SHOULD US SOME
REMEMBER CHU AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON ACTUALLY. WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE I HAVE A MATTER THAT
I ALSO BRING WITH MISTER GLORIA
AND WHOSE HERE IS IT OKAY IF HE
PRESENTS.
AT THIS MOMENT THAT'S FINE WITH
ME THAT WOULD BE SUPER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT'S CALLED
FLEXIBILITY. APPRECIATE THE
FLEXIBILITY. AND OF THE BEST
CHAIR.
NO I'M GOING TO REMEMBER THAT
ONE.
I MEAN I REMEMBER THE.
OKAY THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
IN THAT A. B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY
ONE.
AND.
.
FIRST MY REFERENCE.
SHE WAS.
WITHOUT THAT.
NOW I GET IT.
SO THIS I'VE.
SO IF YOU LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
START.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
FOR ALLOWING MY JOINT AUTHORED
AYE TO PRESENT E. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE.
A MAN CHAIR ACROSS THE COUNTRY
GENERAL SENSE OF UNREST HAS
FILLED MANY COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
MONEY MANY REASONS CONTRIBUTING
TO THIS HAS BEEN INCREASINGLY
COMMON ACQUISITION OF MILITARY
STYLE EQUIPMENT BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
RECOGNIZING THE HEIGHTENED
TENSION BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE PRESIDENT OBAMA
CONVENED A FEDERAL INTER AGENCY
LAW ENFORCEMENT. EQUIPMENT
WORKING GROUP UNDER EXECUTIVE
ORDER THIRTEEN SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
I IN TWENTY FIFTEEN.
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER IN THE SIZE
THE NEED TO BETTER COORDINATE
FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF CERTAIN FEDERAL
EQUIPMENT BY STATE LOCAL AND
TRIBAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AMONG OTHER ISSUESTHE WORKING
GROUP DEVELOPED A LIST OF ITEMS
THAT THEY DETERMINED AFTER
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION. THAT
SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO CERTAIN
CONTROLS PRIOR TO THE TRANSFER
TO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
LAST SUMMER.
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
RESCINDED PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER THIRTEEN SIX
EIGHTY EIGHT ALONG WITH MANY OF
THE POLICIES AND PROTOCOLS
GOVERNING APPROPRIATE
CONSTITUTIONALLY SOUND USES OF
CONTROLLED EQUIPMENT.
TODAY'S BILL AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE REQUIRES ALL LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
OBTAIN APPROVAL BY THE GOVERNING
BODIES.
THE COUNCIL'S BOARD TO
SUPERVISORS A PRIOR TO APPLYING
TO RECEIVING MILITARY EQUIPMENT
MADE AVAILABLE UNDER THE
MILITANT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
MILITARY EQUIPMENT SURPLUS
PROGRAM.
BY ACQUIRING A PUBLIC PLATFORM
TO ALLOW COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE DISCUSSIONS
THE BILL WILL IMPROVE THE
RELATIONSHIPS POLICE HAVE WITH
THE COMMUNITY WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS SEEN AS A PUBLIC
SAFETY SERVICE. RATHER THAN
OCCUPYING FORCE.
IT'S MORE THIS AFTERNOON WE HAVE
WITNESSES.
TO GIVE TESTIMONY BUT TO THE
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER
NOW TO MY JOINT AUTHORS MR CHIU.
THANK YOU WANT TO THANK.
MISTER GLORIA AND.
IMAGINE THIS IS A BILL THAT I
THOUGHT OF MOVING FOR AND THEN I
DISCOVERED OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO WAS ALSO DOING IT SO
WELL. REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO UP TO WORK
TOGETHER AND I WANT TO THANK
AMONG THE MANY SPONSORS I
INDIVISIBLE THE CHAPTERS IN MY
CITY AND AROUND THE STATE FOR.
THEIR SUPPORT OF THIS UP FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE WE NEED TO GIVE
NECESSARY PUBLIC OVERSIGHT OVER
WHEN AND WHY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WOULD NEED
TO ACQUIRE. MILITARY GRADE
WEAPONS
WE KNOW THAT OUR CITIZENS ARE
NOT ENEMY COMBATANTS OUR POLICE
ARE NOT MILITARY GENERALS
AND ARE SPEAKING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE KNOW THAT ALL OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. IN OUR STATE
WANT TO BE PARTNERS IN PUBLIC
SAFETY WITH OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THESE WEAPONS
THAT THEY CARRY SHOULD REFLECT
THAT REALITY.
I DON'T THINK WE WOULD BE HERE
IF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAD
NOT REPEALED THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
OF PREVIOUS PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT HAD
REQUIRED THIS LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY THIS BILL IS NOT
SAYING THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
CANNOT AT SOME POINT RECEIVE
THESE MILITARY WEAPONS ALL WERE
SAYING IS THAT WE NEED
TRANSPARENCY. AND WE NEED
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WITH THAT WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE.
MEMBER SINCE SUPPORT PROJECT TO
SPEAK WITH TWO WITNESSES THE
SAID THIS AFTERNOON YES.
MY NAME IS JOHN LINDSAY POLAND
THEM WITH THE AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE.
MANY LOCAL LEADERS ARE AWARE OF
MILITARY EQUIPMENT ACQUIRED FROM
PENTAGON SURPLUS STOCKS OR
GRANTS FOR PURCHASES.
MUCH LESS INFORMED OF IMPACTS IN
A TO ALTERNATIVES OR ABLE TO
EXERCISE CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT.
AND PUBLIC SAFETY BUDGETS RARELY
DETAIL THE TYPES OF EQUIPMENT
AGENCIES ACQUIRE USING LOCAL
FUNDS.
SAN DIEGO YOU S. D. N. DAVIS
RETURNED A MILITARY ARE ARMORED
VEHICLE AND UC BERKELEY CANCELED
AN ORDER FOR ONE PRECISELY
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO PROCESS FOR
LAWMAKERS AND COMMUNITIES. TO
REVIEW THESE ACQUISITIONS.
EQUIPMENT RANGES FROM BATONS
THAT CAN BE EXTENT EXPANDED WITH
BLADES TO HIGH CALIBER SEMI
AUTOMATIC RIFLES THAT ARE
INCREASINGLY DEPLOYED FOR
ORDINARY POLICING.
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES HAVE
ACQUIRED MORE THAN SIX THOUSAND
MILITARY RIFLES FROM THE US
MILITARY.
WE HAVE THE MILITARY EQUIPMENT
BUT NOT TRANSPARENT GUIDELINES
ABOUT WHAT IS FOR AND HOW IT
WILL BE USED AND NOT USED.
HAVING THE CONVERSATION UP FRONT
RATHER THAN LATER GIVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OVERSIGHT TO PROTECT
TAXPAYER MONIES AND DECIDE LOCAL
STANDARDS FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THEY REPRESENT.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE ALSO
MANDATES REPORTING THAT ALLOWS
LAWMAKERS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TO UNDERSTAND THE ROLE AND
IMPACT OF EQUIPMENT IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OPERATIONS.
IT EMPOWERS OUR LOCAL ELECTED
GOVERNMENTS TO SET BASELINE
STANDARDS FOR WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE IN A PLACE THAT IS
NOT AT WAR. NOR OCCUPIED BY
HOSTILE FORCES
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
MY NAME IS KAT PERKS I AM THE
COFOUNDER OF ANTI POLICE TEAR
PROJECT AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
THE JUSTICE TEAMS NETWORK. I FOR
OVER A DECADE HAVE WORKED WITH
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE SEVERELY BEEN IMPACTED BY
POLICE VIOLENCE.
MILITARIZED POLICING HAS THE
GREATEST IMPACT ON BLACK BODIES
BLACK MEN ARE KILLED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AT A RATE THAT IS
NEARLY THREE TIMES HIGHER THAN
THAT OF WHITE MEN. AND SIXTY
PERCENT OF ALL BLACK WOMEN THAT
ARE KILLED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARE ON ARMED AT THE TIME.
MILITARIZE WEAPONS AND EQUIPMENT
CREATE A MILITARIZED MINDSET
OFFICERS WHO PATROL COMMUNITIES
WITH MILITARY GRADE WEAPONS PETE
RESIDENTS LIKE ENEMY COMBATANTS
RATHER THAN TAXPAYERS WHO FUND
THEIR SALARIES AND WHOM THEY ARE
OBLIGATED TO SERVE. MOST
RECENTLY DEMONSTRATED IN THE
MURDER STEP ON CLARK WHO WAS
SHOT DEAD FOR HAVING A CELLPHONE
AND HANDCUFFED BEFORE BEING
GIVEN MEDICAL TREATMENT.
A PSYCHOLOGICAL AND EMOTIONAL
TOLL OF MILITARIZED POLICING
CAUSES GREAT DISTRESS AND
ALREADY STRESSED COMMUNITIES.
I AM OFTEN ASKED THAT THERE'S
BEEN AN UPSURGE IN POLICE
VIOLENCE OF THE LAST DECADE OR
SO THE ANSWER IS YES AND THAT
UPSURGE IS DIRECTLY CONNECTED TO
POLICE DEPARTMENTS ARMING THE
OFFICERS WITH MILITARY EQUIPMENT
AS DEMONSTRATED BY NUMEROUS
RECENT REPORTS. INCLUDING ONE BY
THE WASHINGTON POST.
ALAMEDA COUNTY AT A MODERATE ON
SIXTEEN GUNNED DOWN BY AN AIR
FIFTEEN WHILE SHE SAT IN HER CAR
SHE WAS UNHARMED AND NOT THE
TARGET.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY MICHAEL NEED
A THIRTY ONE FATALLY SHOT MY
BACK WITH A SUBMACHINE GUN AFTER
HE WAS MISTAKEN PRESS UPS BUT
SUSPECT WANTED AN ARMED ROBBERY
UNHARMED. MONTEREY COUNTY PAY
TWO POINT SIX MILLION TO THE
FAMILY OF A MAN WHO DIED AFTER
SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES THROUGH A
PLASTIC BANG GRENADES OR HIS
WINDOW. WAS LATER DETERMINED HE
WAS NOT INVOLVED WITH THE SWAT
TEAM WITH INVESTIGATED AND WITH
AN ARMED IN THE HOUSE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE
NOT ALWAYS HAVE THIS EQUIPMENT.
AND WE SHOULD RESIST THE
NORMALIZATION OF MILITARIZATION
OF POLICE DEPARTMENTS IS NOT
GOOD FOR COMMUNITIES IT IS NOT
GOOD FOR POLICE.
IF WE CANNOT GET TO A PLACE FOR
THESE TYPES OF EQUIPMENT ARE
BANNED ALTOGETHER WISHED AT
LEAST HAVE THE HUMANITY AND
COMMON SENSE TO ENSURE THOSE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
ABOUT WHAT TYPES OF EQUIPMENT IS
COMING IN THE COMMUNITIES AND
WHAT IT IS BEING USED FOR THIS
IS THE LOWEST POSSIBLE BAR OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS CONSTANTLY
SAYING THEY WANT TO IMPROVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COMMUNITIES
TREATING SOUTH LOS ANGELES EAST
OAKLAND OR THE BAYVIEW LIKE IRAQ
AFGHANISTAN AND SEE IT SYRIA. IS
NOT THE WAY TO DO IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE JOIN US AND YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. IN A POSITION.
THERE.
I'M HERE AS.
THE ACL ALSO.
ALSO HERE IN THE OF THE COURAGE
CAMPAIGN IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
WELL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S A GATHERING OF I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG WHERE
COALITION OF HUNDREDS OF
GRASSROOTS COMMUNITY GROUPS FROM
EVERY SINGLE DISTRICT IN THE
STATE REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS.
WHEN STRONG SUPPORTER AND A
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
TENACITY LIST FOR SACRAMENTO
INDIVISIBLE REGIONAL ACTION
NETWORK REPRESENTING OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND AND INDIVISIBLE MEMBERS
AND DISTRICTS THREE THROUGH
NINE.
IN FULL SUPPORT WE ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
I'M RACHEL BACK REPRESENTING
INDIVISIBLE YELLOW IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I AM EMILY HILL REPRESENTING
INDIVISIBLE COLUSA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
NATE GO MORE WITH INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ERIC HARRIS OF THE CALIFORNIA
AND EE CP IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN LIKELY REPRESENTING
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF.
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA CO
SPONSOR AN URGENT AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
AND YOU'RE MEDINA ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SING NONE
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SING THEN.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS. O.
SKEWS ME COME ON UP
.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH ARE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION ASSOCIATION
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE. AS A PRACTICAL MATTER
TO ACQUISITION OF MILITARY
SURPLUS PROPERTY OFTEN REQUIRES
BIDDERS TO RESPOND QUICKLY.
WITHOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
OBTAIN APPROVAL BY LEGISLATIVE
BODY FOR EACH PURCHASE.
EVEN IF THE BILL ONLY APPLIES TO
THE FIRST TIME.
AND AGENCY SEEKS TO ACQUIRE A
CERTAIN EQUIPMENT EIGHTY
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE
WAS SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES IN THIS
ATTEMPTED PARTICIPATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE TYPE OF
PROPERTY CONTEMPLATED BY DISPEL
IS EXCEEDINGLY FAST
AND INCLUDES ITEMS COMMONLY USED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT INCLUDING
HELICOPTERS AND FIXED WING
AIRCRAFT.
ALSO THE BILL'S LANGUAGE IS
VAGUE AT BEST AS IT ATTEMPTS TO
EXCLUDE ACQUISITION OF ANY FIRE
ARM FOR VAI I'M ACCESSORY
DOESN'T THAT IS DESIGNED TO
LAUNCH SMALL EXPLOSIVE
PROJECTILES.
A DEFINITION THAT ARGUABLY
INCLUDES ALL FIREARMS.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE
INTERFERES WITH THE ABILITY OF
INDEPENDENTLY ELECTED
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS TO
ACQUIRE EQUIPMENT AT A COST
SAVINGS FOR DEPLOYMENT FOR LONG
FORSMAN PURPOSES.
DELEON LIKE THAT SHERIFFS ARE
CERTAINLY CAPABLE OF RESPONDING
TO CONCERNS.
BY THEIR CONSTITUENTS WHEN IT
COMES TO PURCHASING AND
DEPLOYMENT OF APPROPRIATE
EQUIPMENT SHOULD THEY ARISE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WELCOME.
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY PROFESSIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT NINE THOUSAND.
DEPUTY SHERIFF'S INVESTIGATORS
WITH THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE
AND PEACE OFFICERS WITH THE UC
CORONER'S OFFICE.
.
THE WOULD FIRST OF ALL
INCORPORATE BY REFERENCE THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE STATE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION. OF.
ASK YOU TO PAY PARTICULAR
ATTENTION TO THE TIME FRAME
ISSUE WHEN YOU GO THROUGH THE
EXTENDED PERIOD OF A HEARING AND
ALL OF THAT BY THAT TIME. THE
TEN THIRTY THREE EQUIPMENT IS
GONE IT'S IT'S GONE TO SOMEBODY
ELSE.
THE BILL. FEAR HIM WE
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF THE
BILL WE DON'T DISPUTE THAT THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS IS THAT.
WHEN I AM MUCH OF THIS EQUIPMENT
IS ACQUIRED LOCAL AGENCIES
CONVERTED.
TO DIFFERENT USES.
IT DOESN'T HAVE A STRICTLY
SPEAKING MILITARY.
USE.
IT SIMPLY COMES FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE WOULD SUGGEST
THAT RATHER THAN.
THIS.
OF THEY CURRENT LANGUAGE OF
THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE WHICH IS.
BURDENSOME AND COMPLICATED AND.
IT. REALLY WILL RESULT IN.
AGENCIES NOT BEING ABLE TO GET
NEEDED.
EQUIPMENT
WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT.
INSTEAD LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT.
TAKING THE EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE
THAT SEEMED TO BE THE GRAV
AMOUNT OF THE COMPLAINT THAT LED
TO THE BILL TO BEGIN WITH.
AND LET'S LOOK AT HOW WE CAN
CRAFT.
STATE LEGISLATION.
THAT REFLECTS
THE INTENT AND THRUST
OF THAT INITIAL OF OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT WOULD SEEM TO US TO BE. A
RATIONAL APPROACH
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE THAT THE
AUTHORS OF SAID THEY'VE SAID HEY
WE WOULDN'T EVEN BE HERE BUT FOR
THE RECISION. SO LET'S LOOK AT A
CREATIVE WAY TO DO THAT.
BUT.
AS FOR AND WERE WILLING TO WORK.
OF FOR THAT PURPOSE BUT AS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE CURRENT BILL
WE MUST DIE OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY BEING NONE.
OTHER ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SO REMEMBER GRAYSON.
MAYBE NOT SO MUCH QUESTIONS BUT
I DO HAVE A FEW COMMENTS.
AND I DO.
THANK YOU TO OF BOTH.
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AYE I SHARE CONCERNS OF THE
MILITARIZATION. OF OUR LOCAL
SAFETY AGENCIES.
AND THE NEED FOR ANY AND ALL
EFFORTS TO BE PUT FORTH TO BUILD
PUBLIC TRUST.
WITH OUR POLICE FORCE AS A
SERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY. AND
NOT A PRESENT FORCE.
SO WITH THAT.
SUPPORT YA I AM I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT.
THE BILL GETTING OUT COMMITTEE
TODAY HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS ESPECIALLY THE BILL'S
PRESCRIPTIVE NATURE. AND
DICTATING AND RECIPE FORM HOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE TO DO
THEIR JOB AND AGREEMENT THAT
REMAINS A CONSERVE. AS WELL AS
THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
DISCREPANCIES IN THE LIST OF
BANNED ITEMS FOR INSTANCE THERE
MAY BE SOME ITEMS THAT ARE IN
THAT BAND LIST. THAT.
A CITIZEN CAN GO TO OF MILITARY
SURPLUS STORE AND ACTUALLY
PURCHASE THEMSELF.
AND.
OTHER AND IN OTHER ITEMS WHERE
A LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCY
COULD ACTUALLY GO TO A THIRD
PARTY VENDOR. AND PURCHASE IT
OUTSIDE OF THE REVIEW PROCESS
THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY CALLING FOR
BECAUSE IT'S SIMPLY NOT COMING
FROM A MILITARY A TRANSFER FROM
THE MILITARY AND. THEY MAY PAY
THREE FOUR.
TEN TIMES MORE.
THAT WAY AND.
AGAIN I BELIEVE HELICOPTERS WAS
ONE OF THE LISTED ITEMS THAT
THAT COULD POSSIBLY BE OF USE SO
WITH THAT THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS.
I WILL BE WATCHING THE BILL'S A
PROGRESSES FORWARD AND.
REMAIN TO KEEP MY PRIVILEGE TO.
TAKE A DIFFERENT POSITION BUT
HOWEVER RIGHT NOW I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT THE
THE BILL FORWARD AND ADDRESSING
OF THE MILITARIZATION OF OUR OUR
LOCAL AGENCIES.
THANK YOU.
SOME RECOVERY ERA. THINK VERY
MUCH A MADAM CHAIR I.
.
I I I FEEL MUCH AS.
MISTER GRAYSON DOES NOT LET ME
JUST SAY THAT. WHEN I WAS ON
THIS
CITY COUNCIL FOR THE CITY OF
SALINAS.
.
ANY OF THESE PURCHASES WERE
BROUGHT BEFORE OUR.
OUR COUNCIL AND WE MADE THE
DECISIONS.
.
BASED ON THE INFORMATION WERE
GIVEN SOME I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE. THE ISSUE ABOUT HAVING TO
ACT QUICKLY MAYBE THAT.
THE PROCESS HAS CHANGED
IN TERMS OF ACCESSING. THIS
EQUIPMENT ABOUT.
WE CERTAINLY HAD NO PROBLEM.
SAID IT AGENDA ICING SOMETHING
WE MET EVERY WEEK SO IF THERE
WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
EQUIPMENT. UP THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT USUALLY I THOUGHT DID
A PRETTY THOROUGH AND THOROUGH
ANALYSIS AND CAME TO US WITH
THAT ISSUE AND WE WERE ABLE TO
HAVE A PUBLIC HEARING ON IT SO
IT MAKES SENSE TO ME.
ON THE OTHER THE OTHER ISSUE I
WANT YOU TO JUST THINK ABOUT AND
I'M PREPARED TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY BECAUSE I AM OUT I I AGREE
THAT TIME.
PART OF WHAT.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT PARTICIPATE.
BUT.
AYE I AM IT IS. INTRIGUING TO
MEDIA USE THE LANGUAGE OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO LOOK AT THAT
AND TO SEE WHETHER THERE'S A
WAIT OF MER.
WHITE WAS ABOUT.
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER I I DON'T HAVE ANY FROM ME
SO I'M NOT SURE HOW THAT WOULD
BE DIFFERENT.
BUT.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT THAT
MIGHT BE THAT THERE'S SOME
OVERLAP THERE THAT MIGHT BE AND
A WAY TO GO BUT I. I I THINK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION FOR US TO HAVE. AND.
I THINK ALL OF US WANT OUR
POLICE OFFICERS TO BE TREATED
WITH THE UTMOST RESPECT AND PART
OF THAT RESPECT IS IS WORKING
WITH THE COMMUNITY IN HAVING THE
COMMUNITY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE A
STAKE IN THE MATTER AS WELL SO.
BUT I BUT I AM I AM I AM
COGNIZANT OF THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED HERE TODAY SO I'M
GONNA SUPPORT IT TODAY AND WE'LL
SEE HOW IT PROGRESSES.
THEN SHARED IT IS HELPFUL TO THE
COMMITTEE.
DE EVA BUT IT RAN FROM A CELL
USE HERE SHE CAN SPEAK TO THE
ISSUE OF THE CONTRACTS FOR THE
OBAMA EXECUTIVE ORDER I THINK IT
IS LESS THAN WHAT WAS PUT ARE
DESCRIBED BY THE OPPONENTS.
NOTIFYING PLEASE GO PROCEED VERY
MUCH ON.
IN MANY WAYS THIS THIS.
PROPOSED BILL DOES IN FACT NEAR
THE OBAMA EXECUTIVE ORDER BUT IN
IN SEVERAL RESPECTS IT DIFFERS
ONE IMPORTANT ONE IS THAT THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER ACTUALLY HAD A
CATEGORY OF BAND EQUIPMENT THAT
WAS BANNED ALTOGETHER. THIS
PROPOSED BILL DOES NOT MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION BUT RATHER IMPOSES
THIS PROCEDURE FOR POTENTIALLY
ACQUIRING.
THIS MILITARY EQUIPMENT WITHOUT
MAKING THE DISTINCTION OF
WHETHER IT'S BANNED OR NOT SO IN
THAT SENSE IT'S A BIT MORE
PERMISSIVE TOWARD LAW
ENFORCEMENT EVEN THEN THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER OF COURSE
DIDN'T IMPOSE A SPECIFIC LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROCEDURE FOR
APPROVING.
BEEN A IT DIDN'T SET AND IN
THIS LEVEL OF DETAIL OF COURSE
THE PROCEDURE FOR APPROVING
ACQUISITION OF THIS EQUIPMENT.
UP IT DID SORT OF SET SAFEGUARDS
IN PLACE THAT HAD TO BE MET
BEFORE THE PERMISSIVE LIST COULD
BE TRANSFERRED INCLUDING
DEMONSTRATING. THE IMPACT THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT ON THE USE
WHICH IS ALREADY MIRRORED IN IN
THE IN THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
CRESCENTA.
I.
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU BROUGHT
THIS BILL FORD.
IN YOLO COUNTY WE HAD.
A LOT OF HOOPLA OVER A PURCHASE
OF.
A PIECE OF EQUIPMENT THAT NOT
EVERYBODY AGREED TO DO SO THE
NUMBER ONE THING I TAKE FROM
THIS IS TO HAPPEN NOW THERE'S A
PROCESS. AND MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
CLEAR.
TO THE.
.
TO THE LOCALS WHAT HAND HOW
THINGS ARE DONE SO APPRECIATE
GOING THAT BECAUSE WE'VE HAD
QUITE A BIT OF DISCUSSION YOLO
COUNTY. AND IT KIND OF I DID OUR
COMMUNITY. SO IT'S NICE TO HAVE
SOMETHING A PROCESS GOING
FORWARD SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL THE DAY.
MOVE APPROVAL.
THERE.
HEY WE HAVE A MOTION.
SOME OF MY AERO SECOND BY.
STONE.
WHICH I COMPOSE
I KNOW YOU PRESSED FOR TIME
MADAM CHAIR SO ABOUT MY LOCAL
AUTHOR HERE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
DITTO.
OKAY SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
EMOTION IS DUE PASS AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY. ADWARE CURRY AYE AGUIAR
CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CABALLERO AYE COMPARE
AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY NO LACKEY NO
STONE. STONE AYE VOEPEL.
BILLS OUT SIX TO.
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME ALL LET'S
MOVE ONTO ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACE SO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
ONE ASK OF MR GRAYSON TO MOVE
FROM HIS COMFORTABLE CHAIR
BUTTA.
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS BILL AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
THREE. WELL LET ME FIRST START
BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND WE
WILL BE.
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE DISCUSSED WITH THE COMMITTEE
WHICH I'LL MENTION IN A MOMENT A
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A NARROWLY
TAILORED TRANSIT ORIENTED BILL.
IT SAY SUBREGIONAL BILL IMPACTS
A PORTION OF THE BAY AREA ARE
THE BAY AREA THAT IS SUFFERING
FROM TO CRISES.
WE HAVE BEEN THE EPICENTER OF
THE HOUSING CRISIS THE STATE'S
HOUSING CRISIS AND WERE ALSO
EXPERIENCING A VERY INTENSE
CONGESTION CRISIS.
WE KNOW COUNTLESS BAY AREA
RESIDENTS WERE FORCED TO LIVE
FARTHER FROM THEIR JOBS LAST
YEAR AREA RESIDENTS SPENT.
EIGHTY HOURS A YEAR EXTRA IN
TRAFFIC AND CONGESTION ON TOP OF
THEIR ALREADY LENGTHENING
COMMUTES.
THIS BILL WOULD ONLY APPLY TO
LAND AROUND PART THAT IS OWN BY
PART WHICH TODAY ARE WE OF
STATIONS THAT ARE SURROUNDED BY
HUNDREDS OF ACRES. OF PARKING
LOTS WHICH AT NIGHT ARE LOTS
THAT SIT COMPLETELY VACANT
COMPLETELY UNUSED.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE PARK
BOARD TO ESTABLISH BROUGHT TO
THE ZONING STANDARDS TO GOVERN
HIGH DENSITY PARKING.
TO SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT A CITY WOULD HAVE TO
YEARS TO CRAFT LOCAL ZONING
RULES CONSISTENT WITH THAT AND%
WE WOULD REQUIRE TWENTY PERCENT
AFFORDABILITY. IN THOSE MIXED
USE DEVELOPMENTS
THROUGH CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CHAIR WE'VE AGREED TO AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD EXEMPT CITIES THAT
MEET MARKET RATE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OBLIGATIONS UNDER ARENA.
AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT LOCAL
DESIGN GUIDELINES RULE.
THIS MEASURE ALSO ENSURES THAT
THERE IS LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY IT
WOULD ONLY APPLY TO THOSE PARTS
STATIONS WHERE THERE IS A PARK
ELECTED DIRECTOR WHO IS
ACCOUNTABLE TO CONSTITUENTS
AROUND THAT PART STATION.
THE HISTORY WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE.
THERE HAVE BEEN COMMUNITIES
WHERE THERE HAS BEEN HOUSING
BUILT AROUND THEM BUT OFTENTIMES
IN THIS COMMITTEE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES IT WOULD TAKE TEN
FIFTEEN YEARS OR LONGER WITH
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS. AND THEN
AROUND OTHER PARTS STATIONS IN
THE FORTY FIVE YEARS SINCE THE
SPARC STATIONS OPEN.
THERE WAS THERE IS NO HOUSING
THAT IS WHY WE'RE HERE AYE AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
I WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO ONE OF
OUR SPONSORS OF ALONG WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES OF THE
NONPROFIT.
HOUING ASSOCIATION MICHAEL.
CHEROKEE ARE CURRY MEMBERS
MICHAEL AND WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IN THE BARE LAND CAN
GO FOR MORE THAN TEN MILLION
DOLLARS PER ACRE PUBLICLY HELD
LANDS A VALUABLE AND PRECIOUS
RESOURCE.
GIVEN THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INVESTED IN PLANNED TO BE INVEST
IN THE BART SYSTEM. THIS LAND
MUST BE USED WISELY AND PROVIDE
REAL COMMUNITY BENEFITS.
PRIOR TO THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ADOPTION ABORTS TO THE
GUIDELINES.
THERE WAS A MORE THAN TWO YEAR
PUBLIC PROCESS WHICH MY
ORGANIZATION PAGE ALSO
PARTICIPATED IN. AND THE SMARTER
PROGRESSIVE GUIDELINES ARE WELL
KNOWN.
PUBLICLY.
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING POLICY
INCLUDED IN THESE GUIDELINES IS
EXCELLENT.
AND WE NEED THE COOPERATION AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
FOR THIS TO BE IMPLEMENTED.
IN ADDITION THE STATE ALREADY
HAS SIGNIFICANT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCE PROGRAMS THROUGH
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM FOR
EXAMPLE. IN THE TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE WHICH
ALREADY HAVE THESE POLICIES AND
BETTER THAN THE MEN WE NEED THE
SITES TO BE ABLE TO USE THAT LOS
THOSE FINANCING TOOLS. A TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
TO HAVE THE APPROPRIATE DESIGN
STANDARDS AND THE DENSITY IS
NEEDED TO MAKE PROJECTS FEASIBLE
WE NEED LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
ALIGN THEIR ZONING THEIR
POLICIES AND GUIDELINES WITH
THOSE THAT PART HAS LAID OUT.
THROUGH AN EXTENSIVE.
POP PUBLIC PROCESS AND WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE TO BE ABLE TO
BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON
THE SITES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT.
FOR THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
SOUTHERN MATT NAT WITH
LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE
ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS PART OF
THE BILL THINK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR ANOTHER MEMBER
SPOILER BE HAVE THE CITY AND
COUNTY CENSUS GOOD SPORT ABOUT.
JOSHUA STARK ON BEHALF OF
TRANSFORM IN BAY AREA THREE
FIFTY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT I MATTHEW
BAKER WITH PLANNING CONSERVATION
LEAGUE PCL IS NOT TAKEN A FORMAL
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
WE ARE STILL CONSIDERING SOME
OF THE AMENDMENT SUGGESTED BY
PUBLIC ADVOCATES BUT.
WE DO SO A CONCEPTUALLY SUPPORT
THAT THE BASIC TENANTS OF THIS
BILL HAVE PERMITS FORWARD
THINKING.
LET SHEPHERD REPRESENTING THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER ONES ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JASON RILEY CALIFORNIA
CITIES
UNFORTUNATELY WE WE ARE HERE TO
OPPOSE.
.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE YOU
KNOW THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
EFFORTS ON HOUSING WE'VE YOU
KNOW HE'S THE IS THE LEADER I
BELIEVE IN THE IN THIS HOUSE I'M
THAT'S PUSHING HOUSING
LEGISLATION. BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THE WAY THE BILL'S CURLY DRAFTED
WE WE DO HAVE TO OPPOSE OUR
PRIMARY OBJECTION IS THAT WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A CONSTITUTIONALLY
GRANTED POWER FROM THE OVER
MISSILE FAIRS. AND PLEASE POWERS
OF CITIES AND COUNTIES MEMORY
GIVEN TO A SPECIAL DISTRICT AND
THEN WE BELIEVE THAT'S ACTION
CONSTITUTIONAL BUT.
ARE YOU THE ASSUMPTION IS OF
THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS GOING TO
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION AND IT'S
UNCLEAR EXACTLY WHAT THE RIGHT
DECISION IS THE BEST THING WE
CAN GIVE OFFICE. AS THE INTO THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN GUIDELINES
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE TWENTY
SEVEN GUIDELINES BART MADE IT
REALLY CLEAR THAT THEIR BEST
STATIONS.
REALLY COME AT THE DEVELOPMENT
COMES WE WORKS WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND IN A SENSE YOU
KNOW THIS MEASURE WOULD WHAT
ALMOST A FIVE THAT PLANE AND
THEY HAD TO PUT OF MY IN PLACE A
PLAN AND AND NOW. THEY'RE GONNA
SAY WELL YOU KNOW MAYBE CAN
CHANGE THE PLAN AND YOU KNOW NOT
HAVE TO WORK WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO UNDERSCORE
THAT.
BART GETS TO DICTATE BASICALLY
EVERYTHING ON THEIR PROPERTY NOW
THE MINUTES TO HELP THEY JUST
HER DOMINANCE HERE AROUND
DESIGNERS YOU.
BUT PARTS CAN BE THE ONE THAT'S
GONNA DICTATE THE RULES ON THEIR
PROPERTY YES THIS IS ONLY YOU
KNOW RELATED A BAR RIGHT NOW BUT
I WOULD THINK THAT EVERY SPECIAL
DISHES EVERY TRANSIT HE SAID
OWNS PROPERTY. IS GONNA WANT TO
RUN OUT AND GET SIMILAR
TREATMENT FROM THE LEGISLATURE
AND NOT HAVE TO WORK IN A
COLLABORATIVE AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. ONE OF THE OTHER
ISSUES WITH THE BILL TWO IS IT
ALLOWS FOR S. B. THIRTY FIVE
STREAMLINING WITHIN
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE WILL
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS
ARENA AND WE ALL RECALL FROM
LAST YEAR WHEN THE CORNERSTONES
OF S. B. THIRTY FIVE LAST YEAR.
WAS THAT IT IF CITIES CAN MAKE
PROGRESS TOWARDS ARENA THEN THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE TO DO THE
STREAMLINED UNDER SB THIRTY
FIVE.
THIS IS REGARDLESS OF YOUR
MAKING SURE PROGRESS OR NOT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO STREAMLINE
UNDER SB THIRTY FIVE IF BART
WANTS YOU TO DO IT.
WHICH WOULD ESSENTIALLY MEAN
YOU DON'T KNOW SEQUEL.
ON THOSE SITES AND THERE
THERE'S OTHER REQUIREMENTS THAT
THEY HAVE TO ABIDE BY.
WITH THAT UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO
OPPOSE.
THINK YOU. AND CITY GEORGE
REPRESENTING AMERICAN PLAYING
ASSOCIATION UP WE HAVE A POLICY
OF.
SUPPORTING INCREASED DENSITY
AND AFFORDABILITY AROUND TRANSIT
BUT WE CAN'T TO GRIEVE FOR THE
PRESIDENT REASON AS WELL. OF WE
WOULD HAVE EVERY SET SPECIAL
DISTRICT ASKING TO ZONE THEIR
OWN PROPERTY.
WE'D DO SUPPORT THE OPTIONS
THAT WERE IN THE ANALYSIS FOR
THE STATION PLAN.
I HAD KNOWN THAT THOSE WERE
AVAILABLE AND I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD IDEA AND WORKING WITH.
COLLABORATIVELY WE ALSO SUPPORT
A.
MINIMUM DENSITY AND
AFFORDABILITY AROUND THESE
PROJECTS ALLOWING THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET THERE. BUT WE CAN'T AGREE TO
THIS.
OVER RIGHT OF LOCAL PLANNING
FLEXIBILITY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SHARON CAN SOLVE IS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIES OF LIVERMORE
PLEASANTON DANVILLE IN DUBLIN
AND
XIN THINK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SINGER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WHEN YOU ARE HAVING WILK
REPRESENTING CITY OF ALL THE
CREEK IN OPPOSITION.
OTHER ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
YES SOME.
DO YOU WANNA GO.
I I DON'T I AM I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION I GUESS I JUST WANNA
MAKE A STATEMENT AND I I M.. ARE
WERE ACTUALLY A STATEMENT AND
THEN ASKED IF YOU'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THAT. THE LEAGUE AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AYE I AM.
I ACTUALLY REALLY LIKE THIS BILL
AND ONE OF THE REASONS IS.
THAT.
.
THE STATE HAS.
DECREED THAT WORK WE SHOULD BE
INVESTING IN.
TRANSIT IN TRANSIT MODALITIES
TO MOVE PEOPLE.
AND THE.
ONCE THEY'RE RESOURCES THAT
HAVE GONE TOWARDS THAT HAVE BEEN
LIGHT RAIL TRAINS. BART THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS AND.
THAT'S TERRIFIC BECAUSE IT MOVES
PEOPLE BUT FRANKLY NONE OF THE
MONEY GETS SPENT IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE SO
WE DON'T HAVE THAT POPULATION TO
SUPPORT IT.
SO I'M OKAY WITH IS TAKING ALL
OF THIS MONEY NONE OF WHICH WILL
GO TOWARDS RURAL CALIFORNIA AND
PUT IT IN THE CITIES. BUT
THERE'S BEEN A PROMISE MADE IN
THE PROMISES THAT AROUND THE
TRANSIT.
STOPS THAT THERE WILL BE
INCREASED.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HOUSING SO
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO BILL
BENNETT BIG PARKING LOTS.
SO THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT DRIVING
IN TO TAKE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
THEY WALK RIGHT OUTSIDE THEIR
DOOR AND THEY CAN TAKE THE BUS
SO THEY CAN GET THEIR VERY
EASILY. AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS
THAT.
THAT IT IS RARELY HAPPENED
AROUND TRANSIT STOPS AND IN
PARTICULAR. ON I THINK IT'S TRUE
THAT IT'S GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OTHERS TO WEATHER.
FORMS OF TRANSPORTATION IN
PARTICULAR AND NOW A.
WHERE AT THAT COUNCILS AROUND
THE TRANSIT STOPS HAVE DOWNS
OWN?
THE PROPERTY BECAUSE OF PUBLIC.
PROTEST
A PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE AND SO
WE END UP.
PUTTING A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY
INTO THESE TRANSIT STOPS WITH
THE PROMISE AND THE PROMISE
NEVER COMES. TO PASS AND SO I BY
A ON IS THIS THE BEST WAY TO GET
THERE ARE WHICH IS TO KIND OF.
TAKE KIND OF TAKE OVER SOME OF
THIS AYE AYE MAYBE NOT BUT I
THINK YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT PATH.
IT'S MY BELIEF THAT WHAT WHAT
WOULD BE ANOTHER WAY TO DO IT IS
TO REQUIRE THAT BEFORE ANY.
STATE DOLLARS ARE SPENT ON
TRANSIT. THAT THERE HAS TO BE IN
AGREEMENT WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THEY SIGNED OFF ON INCREASING
THE DENSITIES AND AND IF IN FACT
THEY MOVED TO REDUCE DENSITIES
THAT THEY HAVE TO PAY THE MONEY
BACK.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GET THE DENSITY WE
NEEDS AROUND THESE TRANSIT STOPS
IT'S A WASTE OF. TAXPAYERS MONEY
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A BROKEN
PROMISE AND SO I'M I'M HOPING
THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH. THE THE LOCALS BECAUSE I'M
A BIG BELIEVER AND LOCAL CONTROL
AND IN THE ABILITY TO CONTROL
AND USED IN PARTICULAR AND I
KNOW BOTH YOU COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
SO. I'M IN SUPPORT THIS TODAY
BECAUSE I REALLY THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
AND.
AND AND HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE
SO THAT.
THAT IN FACT LOCALS ARE AT THE
TABLE WORKING ON ON THESE KINDS
OF PROJECTS WHERE WE CAN REALLY
GET THE HOUSING THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED. SO THAT WERE
NOT IMPACTING OTHER COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE WE'RE PUSHING HOUSING
FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY.
IF I COULD JUST RESPOND FOR
SECOND I REALLY APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS AND FIRST OF ALL OF
COURSE OUR WE LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE OUR ENGAGEMENT WITH
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ABOUT THIS
BILL AND. AND HOW CRAFT IS
CAREFULLY BUT I THINK YOUR POINT
IS EXTREMELY WELL TAKEN IF WE
WERE DOING THIS TODAY.
WE SHOULD SAY THAT ANY
JURISDICTION THAT'S GONNA
RECEIVE SIGNIFICANT TRANSIT
DOLLARS TO BUILD SOMETHING THE
SCALE OF A PARK STATION. NEEDS
TO COMMIT TO SMART GROWTH AND
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AROUND THAT
STATION AND IF IT WERE UP TO ME.
THAT SHOULD HAPPEN FORTY FIVE
YEARS AGO BUT IT DIDN'T AND WHAT
WE'RE FACED WITH AT THIS TIME
ARE ARE ARE DOZENS OF STATIONS
SURROUNDED BY HUNDREDS OF ACRES
OF PARKING LOTS.
AND THAT'S NOT FAIR I THINK TOO.
TO THE REGION THAT'S
EXPERIENCING A HOUSING
CONGESTION CRISIS AND IT'S NOT
FAIR TO YOUR DISTRICT THAT
DIDN'T RECEIVE THE TRANCE
DOLLARS.
SO.
I HAD THOUGHT THAT IN THE BAY
AREA WE OUGHT TOCONDITION FOR
FUTURE FOR THE FUTURE ANY
JURISDICTION THAT ONCE RECEIVED
DOLLARS. HOUSE TO COMMIT BUT WE
CAN'T UNRING THAT BELL AT THIS
POINT BUT WHAT WE CAN DO IS TO
SUGGEST THAT ON BART ON LANDS WE
SHOULD DO A BETTER JOB. THAN
JUST BUILDING PARKING LOTS BUT I
LOOK FOR DEBT HOPEFULLY WORKING
WITH YOU TO MOVE. RELATED
PROPOSALS LIKE THAT IN THE
FUTURE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OF QUESTION
AS FAR AS OUR COMMITMENT TO
WORKING WITH OPPOSITION AND MY
OFFICE DOOR AND STAFF ARE OPEN
AND AVAILABLE. TO SPEAKING WITH.
OPPOSITION IF AT ANY TIME THEY
WOULD LIKE TO COME BY AND VISIT.
AND TALK WITH US.
SO WE'RE OPEN TO THAT AYE A
MADAM CHAIR IF I IF I MAY I KNOW
THAT.
BART HAS TAKEN A NEUTRAL
POSITION BUT I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS.
IF WE COULD HAVE A BAR TODD
REPRESENTATIVE COME UP AND
ANSWER. AND WE FIND WE DO HAVE A
BAR REPRESENTATIVE.
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
JUST AND AND IF IF I'M THE I
DON'T TAKE THE CHAIRS JOB IF I
MAY UM AT YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHIANG COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
DIRECTOR NICK TO SUFFER WITH
SOME THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
BOUGHT.
UNLIKABLE MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
BOTTOM DIRECTLY ELECTED.
SO A. JUST AS A AS A PRESET ALL
THIS WERE REALLY SHORT ON TIME
SO IF YOU COULD KEEP YOUR
ANSWERS I'M JUST I'VE GOT A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS THAT I WANT
TO ASK YOU SO. I'VE BEEN KEEP
GRAMPS WAS REALLY CONCISE I'LL
KEEP MY QUESTIONS EVEN MORE
CONCISE.
ON THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
DOES THIS SET A STATEWIDE
PRESIDENT OR OR SOME OF ASKED
THAT QUESTION DOES A SET OF
STATEWIDE PRESIDENT I DON'T
THINK SO BOUGHT IS UNIQUE IN THE
COUNTRY IN THAT IT'S A DIRECTLY
ELECTED TRANSIT BOARD.
AND WE ALSO HAVE BY FAR THE
HIGHEST RIDERSHIP OF ANY RAIL
AGENCY IN THE STATE SO WE THINK
THAT.
IN ADDITION PART IS THE SINGLE
LARGEST LANDOWNERS OF PRIORITY
DEVELOPMENT SITES
IN THE FIVE COUNTY AREA WHICH
ITS UPS.
I THINK YOU KNOW BART AT AND
IT'S BEEN SAID COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT PART IS ON ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PUBLIC. AND.
HOW WITH THAT HOW WAS THAT?
THAT THAT PHRASE
TO BE TAKEN.
SO WHERE WOULD THE BUBBLE
DIRECTORS IS DIRECTLY ELECTED SO
ARE WE AT PRIMARILY ACCOUNTABLE
TO THE VOTERS.
AT SCHOOL ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE.
AND.
WE REPRESENT LOGICDISTRICTS
THAN TYPICAL CITY COUNCIL IS
REPRESENT DISTRICTS ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
BUT IT'S SIMILAR TO A LOTTA
COUNTY SUPERVISORS.
NO WITH.
WILL THIS BECAUSE YOU ARE
DIRECTLY ELECTED IN MAY I REMIND
EVERYONE THAT THIS BILL ONLY
AFFECTS.
AREAS WHERE THERE IS A DIRECTLY
ELECTED.
MEMBER ON THE BART BOARD.
AND SO WITH THAT.
AND I CAN SEE THIS WITH
EXPERIENCE.
HOW IS BART'S INTENT OR OR
ABILITY TO COLLABORATE WITH
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IS THERE A
CHANGE OR? AT THE REASON WHY I
ASK THIS QUESTION ONE WHEN I WAS
ON THE COUNCIL.
IN MY CITY AND ALSO WAS MAYOR.
THERE WASN'T A HUGE CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT IN IN THE
CITY THAT.
THAT BART WAS GOING TO DO TO
THEIR DOWNTOWN BARDS OR TO OUR
DOWNTOWN BART STATION.
AND.
PARK WAS THE ONE THAT ACTUALLY
INITIATED CONTACT WITH THE CITY
CAME IN AND MET WITH THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS AS WELL AS CITY STAFF.
AS A MATTER OF FACT THE CITY WAS
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO WAY AND
EVEN ON THE STYLE OF THE LACK OF
THE LIGHT STANDARDS.
THEY WERE GOING TO BE INSTALLED
ON BART PROPERTY.
TO FIT THE SURROUNDING.
DEVELOPMENT LANDSCAPE SO WHAT
IS THE.
WHAT'S THE INTENT OF BART AS
FAR AS A ARE YOU USING THIS BILL
TO TRY TO MINIMIZE LOCAL
COLLABORATION OR.
SO YOU YOU KNOW THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION BOND HAS A LONG
STANDING POLICY AND PRACTICE OF
DEEP COLLABORATION NOT JUST WITH
THE CITIES AND COUNTIES ELECTED
BODIES BUT WITH COMMUNITIES AS
WELL. AND THAT WILL CONTINUE ROM
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THIS LITTLE
I'M COMES INTO EFFECT WE EVEN IT
IN.
IN VERY RECENTLY PUT IN PLACE A
PROGRAM WHERE WE ARE INVESTING
BOUGHT DOLLARS IN CITIES. AND
COUNTIES TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE TO ACCESS BART STATION.
AND OBVIOUSLY HAVE THE
COLLABORATION WITH THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES WITHOUT REGARD I'M
AND I I DID THIS THIS WOULD WE
WE WE ARE THERE IS NO OTHER WAY
TO RIP TO RUN OVER A. A SORT OF
AN EFFICIENT MASS TRANSIT SYSTEM
OTHER THAN HAVING DEEP
COLLABORATION WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT WAS
SOMETHING THANK YOU AND. IF I
MAY FOR THIS.
THIS SIDE SECOND A LAST
QUESTION HERE IF I MAY. ARE AS
FAR AS PARTS CONCERNED THAT AND
I'LL LET ME GIVE SOME BACKGROUND
TO THIS THIS QUESTION THE
LARGEST CITY IN MY DISTRICT
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HOUSING ESTIMATES.
FOR THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
THE LARGEST CITY IN MY DISTRICT
HAS ONLY DEVELOPED A HUNDRED AND
NINE HOMES AS FAR AS A NET
INCREASE.
AND THAT'S FOR.
THE LARGEST CITY IN MY DISTRICT.
A HUNDRED NINE HOMES AND WE'RE
IN A HOUSING CRISIS
AS MATTER OF FACT IF YOU WANTED
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION IT'S
ARENA OBLIGATIONS.
THIS CITY HAS ONLY DEVELOPED A
POINT SEVEN PERCENT OF ITS
MARKET RATE HOUSING. TWO POINT
FOUR PERCENT OF ITS LOW INCOME
HOUSING POINT SEVEN PERCENT OF
ITS LOW OF ITS LOW INCOME OR
VERY LOW INCOME FOR TWO POINT
FOUR
OF ABOVE MARKET RATE HOUSING.
AND SO WITH THAT CONTEXT
HOW IS IT THAT THIS BILL WOULD
IMPACT CITIES THAT ARE WORKING
WITH BART TOT GUIDELINES.
I'M SO CITIES THAT A.
ALREADY MOVING FORWARD AND%
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF CITIES TO
SO AND I'M THE STATION THE
BOTTOM LINE AND I'M A NE IN A
WAY THAT BUT THAT IS SORT OF
APPROPRIATE. FOR THAT LOCATION
THIS WOULD NOT HAVE A BIG IMPACT
ON THEM BUT BOUGHT DOES I KNOW
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY ACRES OF
LAND IMMEDIATELY ADJACENT TO ITS
STATIONS WHICH IS. I'M WHICH IS
CURRENTLY PARKING LOTS OF MEN ON
THAT LAND WE COULD BUILD AYE WE
ESTIMATE ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
UNITS
ACCORDING TO BOX CURRENT TEO DE
GUY LA GUIDELINES SEVEN THOUSAND
OF WHICH WOULD BE AFFORDABLE. AS
WELL AS FOUR AND A HALF MILLION
SQUARE FEET OF COMMERCIAL SPACE.
AND.
AND SO THIS I'M THIS BILL WOULD
UNDOUBTEDLY I'M ALLOW BART I'M A
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ARM TO DELIVER ON
THOSE GOALS. BRECHT AND AND I I
SAY THIS BUT OR EVEN ASK THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN
SAID THAT.
WE JUST NEED TO BRING PEOPLE TO
THE TABLE AND TALK WE NEED TO
TALK. I KNOW SITTING ON COUNCIL
THAT WAS THE RHETORIC WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT THE HOUSE AND WE NEED
TO TALK ABOUT GETTING MORE
HOUSING. AND YET OUR POLICIES
ARE ARE NOT IN ALIGNMENT WITH
WHAT WE'RE SAYING WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT.
AND SO WE'RE FINALLY GETTING TO
A POINT WHERE THE CRISIS IS SO
BAD I I WAS JUST AT A COMMUNITY
DID TO.
COMMUNITY EVENTS THIS PAST
WEEKEND AND THE NUMBER ONE TOPIC
THEY WANTED TO TALK ABOUT WAS
HOUSING.
AND SO WITH THAT YEAH I'M MY
LAST QUESTION.
IF BART
DOESN'T.
DOESN'T HOUSING ON THESE NEW
YOU MAY HAVE AN ANSWER MAY NOT
HAVE AN ANSWER THIS BUT IF PART
DOESN'T PUT HOUSING ON THESE
PROPERTIES.
THEN IS IT TRUE THAT BARK CAN
PRETTY MUCH.
WHATEVER FACILITY THEY WANT UP
ON THESE PROPERTIES WITHOUT VERY
MUCH LOCAL REVIEW AT IF ANY AT
ALL. YES SIR BOND CURRENTLY HAS
FULL LAND USE AUTHORITY.
FOR WHAT IS TRANSPORTATION
RELATED IMPROVEMENTS
I'M FOR INSTANCE SO WE COULD
HAVE BOUGHT COULD ON ITS OWN
WITHOUT ANY.
INTERFACE WITH THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BUILD A SORT OF AN
EIGHT OR NINE STORY PARKING
GARAGE
FOR INSTANCE I'M AND.
AND THIS BILL OBVIOUSLY WOULD
HAVE.
WOULD WOULD WOULD WOULD NOT
ALLOW BOX TO BUILD WHATEVER IT
WANTED FROM A HOUSING
PERSPECTIVE WOULD REQUIRE BOUGHT
TO WORK WITH THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ESTABLISH
GUIDELINES ABOUT REGARD. RIGHT
OR OR POSSIBLY OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT MAINTENANCE
FACILITY ARE YES THEY CAN BUILD
A MULTI STORY. OI COULD BUILD
YOU KNOW TRACKS THROUGH A
COMMUNITY IF IF IT SO WHAT'S
INTERESTING HERE IS THE THING
THAT WE NEED THE MOST.
AND THE BAY AREA IS HOUSING.
AND THAT'S THE THING WERE
STIFLING THE MOST.
AND AND.
SO I WOULD SAY THAT WE NEED TO.
GIVE BART AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COLLABORATE AND WORK TOGETHER.
TO ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS
THAT WE NEED TO MEET FOR FOR
PUBLIC AND FOR CONSTITUENTS AND
THAT'S HOUSING.
SO WITH THAT I DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
SO REMEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I THINK.
CO AUTHOR GRAYSON JUST.
A VERY ELOQUENTLY MADE THE CASE
FOR THE BILL THIS IS A BILL THAT
PROMISES INVESTMENT TO AND MIXED
USE.
DEVELOPMENT EXACTLY WHERE WE
NEED IT I THINK I'M A CO AUTHOR
ALREADY BUT IF I'M NOT. A HAPPY.
LIKED.
AS I AM MONTH SO MANY HERE NILES
CELLS ARE CHIU IDEA.
HOME OF THE MISTAKE.
AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS SINCE YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BART SHOWING UP
TODAY
SO THEY WILL HAVE QUESTIONS ARE
FOR US.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
I'M MORE WANTED TO SPEAK TO THE
BILLS SUBSTANCE I'M SO.
PORTING OF THE BILL.
AND.
.
I SEE IT FURTHER IN OUR.
GENERAL APPROACH FROM S. B.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE DARRYL
STEINBERG SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES.
OUR IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
AS AN OFFICER OF THE LEAGUE I
ACTUALLY MANAGE.
S. B. THREE SEVENTY FIVE TWO THE
LEAGUE DOES A HOUSING COMMITTEE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
I MEMBER KNOWS COMMITTEE SAYING
MY COLLEAGUES IS YOU'RE STRONG
WITH WHERE THEY'D BE ON CAROL
STEINBERG SPILL.
SINCE I ALWAYS HAVE A QUOTE.
I QUOTE FROM FDR.
WHICH IS STILL APPLICABLE TODAY.
ONE THING IS SURE.
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
WE HAVE TO DO THE BEST WE KNOW
HOW AT ANY MOMENT.
IF IT DOESN'T TURN OUT RIGHT WE
CAN MODIFY IT AS YOU GO ALONG.
YOU KNOW IN THE FACE OF PROBLEMS
YOU JUST HAVE TO TRY TO BE A
PROBLEM SOLVER TO THE BEST YOU
CAN.
I THINK IT IS SIGNIFICANT I
DON'T VIEW THIS ACTUALLY IS.
SEVEN A RULE HERE FOR EVERY
SPECIAL DISTRICT.
BECAUSE THIS IS A.
TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT.
THIS BEEN AROUND FOR DECADES.
SINCE THE SIXTIES.
ARM.
AND THERE ARE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN SUPPORT OF THAT TRASH
TRISH OF CHURCHES GONE IN.
AND THIS POLICY ALIGNS WITH HOW
DO WE. CAPITALIZE ON THIS PUBLIC
INVESTMENT.
SO I THINK WE'RE DEALING WITH OF
NARAL CLASS A SPECIAL DISTRICT.
OR WE HAVE APPRECIATED BY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF PUBLIC
INTEREST ALIGNED WITH CLEAR
STATEWIDE POLICY.
AND LOOKING HOW TO LEVERAGE THAT
INVESTMENT TO FURTHER THAT
INVESTMENT.
.
AND I WANT TO POINT OUT ACTUALLY
THE FACT THAT THIS GOES BACK
TO THE SIXTIES.
ARE.
I ACTUALLY WANT TO MAKE THE
OBSERVATION.
THE FACTS WILL COME OUT IN THE
WASH WILL SEE HOW THIS POLICY.
WORKS OUT IN TIME.
BUT IT IS A REALITY WHEN YOU
HAVE NEIGHBORHOODS A BEEN LONG
ESTABLISHED GOING BACK TO THE
SIXTIES.
AS PEOPLE AGE.
FOLKS MOVE OUT OF THOSE HOMES A
MOVEMENT OTHER SORTS OF HOUSING
I SEE THAT IN MY DISTRICT WHICH
IS A. THE AVERAGE AGE EIGHT
SANDIFER'S IS.
OLDER THAN FOR EXAMPLE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE A NEIGHBORHOOD
A A COMMUNITY OF ALL. SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES
WHEN PEOPLE ARE AGENT WHEN THEY
MOVE INTO COMMITTEE CARE FOR
SAYS OTHER SORTS OF THINGS.
RESTAURANTS AND OTHER THINGS
ACTUALLY START TO SUFFER.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE NOT IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD BELIEVED IN THEIR
HOME DRIVING A LOCAL RESTAURANT
AT NIGHT TO EAT.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF RESTAURANTS
THAT ARE LONG ESTABLISHED
RESTAURANT EIGHT THE SENATE
DISTRICT THAT HAVE CLOSED AND
STRUGGLED.
BECAUSE PEOPLE MOVE OUT OF THEIR
HOMES AND YOU DON'T HAVE
REPLACEMENT POPULATION.
SO I ACTUALLY FEEL THERE IS AN
ASPECT OF THE BILL LIKE THIS AS
A TEST BED.
IT IS SOOOO GENEROUS IT IS
UNIQUE CLASS OF PROPERTY.
IT WILL SUPPORT A CLEARLY
STATEWIDE GOAL.
AND AS A STARTS TAKING THESE
COMMUNITIES AND BRING IN
ADDITIONAL HOUSING IN ADDITION
DOLLARS JUST.
ADDITIONAL DISPOSAL INCOME INTO
THESE AREAS.
I ACTUALLY THINK IT WILL CONFER
A BROADER ECONOMIC BENEFITS
SUPPORTING.
SHOPS AND RESTAURANTS AND OTHER
SORTS OF THINGS AT ALL WILL
BENEFIT FROM.
SO IN THAT SENSE I I FEEL.
ON THE POLICY MERITS OF HOUSING
I THINK THE CASE IS MADE.
BUT IN TERMS OF SUSTAINING
FAVORABLE DYNAMICS AND LONG
ESTABLISHED COMMUNITIES OF THE
BAY AREA.
I I ACTUALLY FEEL IT IT OFFER
SOME IMPORT POTENTIAL.
AND.
ALL OF OUR WORK ON A BE AIMING
TO TRY TO RELEASE POSITIVE
ENERGY.
IN THE COMMITTEES WERE POLICIES
WILL IMPACT I THINK.
I PERSONALLY THINK ITS BROADER
EVEN THAN THE CASE I HEARD HERE
I THINK WILL. SUPPORT.
RESTAURANTS AND OTHER SERVICES
IN ESTABLISHED COMMUNITIES ALONG
BARTTELOT MONTHS.
AND THAT'LL BE BENEFICIAL THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS AS WELL.
ANY OTHER ROOM ANYONE OTHER ROOM
CLEAN MEMBERS.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BOUGHT WALDRON
THINKING ASSIST WONDERING WHERE
PEOPLE PARK IF YOU DO THE
DEVELOPMENT YOU WANTED
SO PARKING WOULD STILL BE A
PERMISSIBLE OPTION OF FOR A
MIXED USE DEVELOPMENT THE IDEAS
AT THIS POINT AROUND THESE PARTS
STATIONS. WE'VE HUNDREDS OF
ACRES OF SIMPLE PARKING LOT
THAT'S ALL WE HAVE AND WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING IS LET'S BILL
HOUSING ON TOP OF THAT LET'S
BUILD A MIXED USE DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION AS. TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
A PARK STATION TO BE ABLE TO
WALK AROUND IS MISTER COOLEY
SUGGESTED TO THE RESTAURANT TO
THE CORNER STORE. TO YOUR HOME
AND TO BE ABLE PARK UNDERNEATH
IT IF THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
COMMUNITY WOULD LIKE TO DO SO
WE'RE NOT PRECLUDING PARKING.
MALES SHOULD BOND HAS A UP
PARKING REPLACEMENT POLICY.
WHICH IS SO CLOSELY LINKED TO
THE DEVELOPMENT ON BOUGHT LAND
THAT OVER THE PAST SINCE
INCEPTION UP PRIVATE DEVELOPERS
AND ACTUALLY PAID FOR THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WHAT THE
BOUGHT PARKING STRUCTURE BUT.
WHAT THE PARKING STRUCTURES TO
BE BUILT ON THE? BOTTOM LINE AND
I'M HAS.
I SAID TRYING TO GOING TO
DEVELOPMENT HAS TAKEN OVER THE
SUB IS PARKING LOTS WE BASICALLY
TAKE THAT WHAT WAS ONCE FLAT AND
PUT IN A. IN A STRUCTURE IN MANY
PLACES.
AND ONE OTHER QUICK POINT IS THE
POINT OF BUILDING HOUSING ON TOP
OF.
TRANSIT IS SO THAT FOLKS DON'T
HAVE TO OWN CARS BECAUSE WE'VE
SEEN A MASSIVE EXPANSION AND
POPULATION AND ALL THOSE FOLKS
ARE PURCHASING CARS DRIVING IN
THIS PARKING LOTS AND PARKING
THEM. IF WE BUILT HUNDREDS OF
UNITS ON TOP OF THAT WE COULD
AVOID THAT CONGESTION AND THAT
PARKING IS FOLKS JUST HOP OUT OF
ROLL OUT OF BED. AND GET ON TO
THE BART STATION GO TO WORK AT A
HIGH COST A JOBCENTRE IN THE
COME BACK.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE
A SECOND HIM REGISTROS SECOND.
CAIRO SECOND.
OKAY SO.
I WILL A. REOPEN GO AHEAD
WATCHERS.
WHICH ARTISTS
CLOSE AND THEN I'LL GIVE ME MY
STATEMENT JUROR ARE HAPPY TO
HERE'S HARVEY'S LIKE WOULD YOU
LIKE AND CLOSE. OKAY.
COLLEAGUES VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION I THINK ABOUT A
CHANCE TO MISTER GRAYSON SALAS
CHANCE.
TO TO MANY OF YOU JUST A FEW.
POINTS AND THEN I WILL.
JUST WRAP UP OF THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES HAD SUGGESTED THAT
SOMEHOW THIS WAS GOING BEYOND
WHERE S. B. THIRTY FIVE POINT
AND I WANT TO. BE VERY CLEAR
THAT WE'VE ACCEPTED AN AMENDMENT
INITIALLY THE FIRST VERSION OF
THIS BILL SAID THAT REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER CITY WAS MEETING ITS
WIENER NUMBERS WE WANTED TO
BUILD ADDITIONAL HOUSING. WE'VE
AMENDED THE BILL SO THAT IF THE
CITY IS HITTING ITS RAINY
NUMBERS WITH REGARDS TO MARKET
RATE AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING THEY
WOULD NOT HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
OBLIGATION. ANOTHER WORDS A
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE PARKING
LOTS OF THEY WANT SECONDLY OF.
THERE'S A SUGGESTION.
THAT'S THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO FOSTER PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND AND PART%
AND THE AND THE REALITY IS. THAT
HAS BEEN HAPPENING THIS BEEN
HAPPENING FOR MANY MANY YEARS
BUT FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN TWENTY
YEARS INTO CONVERSATIONS THAT
PART AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO HAVE A LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
BUILD. HAVE NOT LEAD TO ANYTHING
SO WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING NEW
AYE AND.
THE LAST THING I WANNA SAY IS I
KNOW.
WE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR ABOUT OTHER AMENDMENTS
WERE STILL OBVIOUSLY VERY OPEN
TO THINKING ABOUT ADDITIONAL
APPROACHES AND WE JUST SAW YOUR
COMMITTEE NOW SINCE LAST NIGHT
AND CERTAINLY THERE SOME IDEAS
IN HERE THAT THAT WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT AND LOOK FORWARD
TO. ENGAGE WITH YOU IN THAT
CONVERSATION BUT AT THE END THE
DAY THIS IS A BILL.
ABOUT ADDRESSING HOUSING CRISIS
REDUCING CONGESTION IN
GREENHOUSE GASES INCREASING
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP JOBS
ARE AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN TAKE
THIS STEP WITH A NARROWLY
TAILORED TRANSIT ORIENTED BILL
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CLOSING COMMENTS
WE'VE HAD MANY DISCUSSIONS I
APPRECIATE EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM. AYE A.
WILL BE VOTING NO ON THIS
MEASURES TODAY. BUT I SUPPORT
THE GOALS BEHIND IN THE ATTEMPT
BEHIND THE BILL BUT HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PRODUCT.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR TAKING FOR ADDRESSING SOME
OF THE LOWER TIER ISSUES TO
ENSURE THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES
CAN DO DESIGN REVIEW. ON THE
BART OWN PROPERTIES AND SPECIFY
THAT THE PROJECT STREAMLINING
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL ARE FOR
THOSE CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT
ARE NOT. MEETING THEIR CERTAIN
RINA OBLIGATIONS
I UNDERSTAND YOUR FRUSTRATION
TRUSTS AND.
I STILL HAVE FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERNS ABOUT ABOUT OVERRIDING
LOCAL CITY AND COUNTY LAND USE
AUTHORITY GRANTED BY THE
CONSTITUTION.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE PRECEDENT
FOR OTHER SPECIAL DISTRICTS
SIMMERED APART TO COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND REQUEST THE SAME
TREATMENT ON THEIR OWN PARCELS
I'VE HAD TO CALL ME.
THE BILL'S APPROACH DOES NOT
ENCOURAGE COLLABORATION A
PARTNERSHIP AMONGST LOCAL
AGENCIES AND DOING GOOD
DEVELOPMENT.
I REALLY UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM THIS AND SO.
I KNOW THAT NOT EVERYBODY
AGREES WITH ME MY FRUSTRATION IS
IS THAT. WE HAVE COUNCILS.
THAT PUT UP THE WALL FROM US
FROM DOING SOME GOOD PROJECTS
I'VE HAD IN MY DISTRICT AS WELL.
MY CONCERN IS I DON'T FEEL THAT
AT THIS POINT THAT I CAN TAKE
LOCAL CONTROL WAY. I FEEL LIKE
THIS IS LOCAL CONTROL AND BART.
FEEL LIKE WE'RE GOING PART AND
LOCAL CONTROL
SO THAT'S WHERE MY FEELING TODAY
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE BILL I'M
SURE WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS JUST BY. LOOKING
AROUND THE ROOM AND I.
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU AS
WELL.
SO WITH THAT SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AGUIAR CURRY.
AGUIAR CURRY NO WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM.
BLOOM I HAVE A HERO CABALLERO
AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
STONE.
STONE I'VE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO.
SO HE. WENT TO.
FIVE TO THREE.
BOB A THREE OUT CAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY.
WE'RE READY FOR ITEM NINE MS
QUIRK SILVA.
WHICH IS.
A. B. TWO SIX FIVE FOUR.
I THINK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR DEDICATED WORK ON THIS
LEGISLATION WE KNOW YOU WORK
VERY HARD FOR US AND WE
APPRECIATE IT. A AB TWO SIX FIVE
FOUR WOULD AUTHORIZE THE COUNTY
OF ORANGE AND ORANGE COUNTY
FLOOD CONTROL DISTRICT TO USE
THE DESIGN BUILD PROJECT
DELIVERY METHOD. FOR REGIONAL
STORM WATER FACILITIES.
OUR STATE CONTRACTING CODE HAS
AUTHORIZED THE DESIGN BUILD
METHOD FOR PROJECT DELIVERY FOR
SPECIFIED PROJECTS ELIGIBLE FULL
PROJECTS INCLUDE BUILDINGS WATER
AND WASTEWATER FACILITIES
PARKING RECREATIONAL FACILITIES
AND PUBLIC RAIL TRANS.
TRANSIT AMONGST OTHERS
HOWEVER PROJECTS SUCH AS LOCAL
AND REGIONAL STORM WATER
FACILITIES ARE NOT INCLUDED. THE
CURRENT EXCLUSION OF STORM WATER
FACILITIES PRECLUDES THE ABILITY
FOR A CONTRACTOR IN A PUBLIC
AGENCY TO COLLABORATE.
TO COLLABORATE ON CERTAIN
COMPLEX IN FROM INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THROUGH THE AUTHORIZED
USE OF THE DESIGN BUILD METHOD
AB TWO SIX FIVE FOUR. WILL
PROVIDE THE COUNTY WITH PROJECT
DELIVERY AND SIGNIFICANT COST
SAVINGS ECIALLY
OF THE PENDING.
STORM WATER AND FLOOD CONTROL
PROJECTS SLATED TO BETTER SERVE
ORANGE COUNTY RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES.
WITH ME TODAY FOR TESTIMONY WE
HAVE NARDI CON WHO IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR ORANGE COUNTY
PUBLIC WORKS AND AMY JENKINS WHO
IS REPRESENTING ORANGE COUNTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ON RT CON DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ORANGE COUNTY PUBLIC WORKS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY. AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR WILL PROVIDE THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE AND THE ORANGE
COUNTY FLOOD CONTROL DISTRICT
WITH THE OPTION OF DELIVERING
COMPLEX PROJECTS THROUGH A TEAM
APPROACH. UTILIZING PROVEN
DESIGN BUILD ADVANTAGES SUCH AS
EARLY CONTRACTOR INVOLVEMENT.
COST PREDICTABILITY ENHANCE
SCHEDULE CONTROLS AND RISK
MITIGATION. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
COUNTIES TO UTILIZE DESIGN BUILD
BUILDINGS ONLY ARE RECENTLY
COMPLETED ANIMAL CARE FACILITY
WHICH IS A STATE OF THE ART
THIRTY THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
STRUCTURE WAS SUCCESSFULLY
DELIVERED USING DESIGN BUILD.
THE SINGLE POINT OF CONTACT FOR
THE DESIGN AND GENERAL
CONTRACTOR TEAM WORKED CLOSELY
WITH THE COUNTY IN REAL TIME TO
RESOLVE DESIGN ENGINEERING AND
CONSTRUCTION ISSUES. WHICH
PRODUCE SCHEDULE AND COST
SAVINGS EXISTING STATUTE DOES
NOT PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES TO
UTILIZE DESIGN BUILD FOR MANY
OTHER PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS SUCH
AS FLOOD WATER CONTROL WHICH
MAKE UP A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
THE COUNTIES CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY FOUR
INCLUDES ALL OF THE EXISTING
PROTECTIONS ESTABLISHED BY
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION.
AUTHORIZING THE USE OF DESIGNED
BUILT FOR FLOOD CONTROL
IMPROVEMENTS HARBOR SOME BEACHES
AND BIKEWAYS.
AS A RESULT OF AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR THE COUNTY WILL BE
ABLE TO DELIVER IMPORTANT
PROJECTS WITH IMPROVE PROCESS.
REDUCE LITIGATION RISK AND
ENHANCE COST SCHEDULE
PREDICTABILITY THIS IS OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE TO THE
COUNTY AS VOLATILE REVENUE
STREAMS. EVER INCREASING
CONSTRUCTION COSTS AND PUBLIC
TRUST REMAIN PRIMARY CONCERN
WHEN DELIVERING CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY FOUR ALSO
LIMITS THE NUMBER OF INSTANCES
PER YEAR THAT DESIGN BUILD MAY
BE UTILIZED PROVIDING A MEASURED
APPROACH THAT ALLOWS ONGOING
FOCUSED EVALUATION OF THE
PROCESS.
IN CLOSING THE DESIGN BUILD
DELIVERY METHOD IS BEST UTILIZED
FOR COMPLEX HIGH RISK PROJECTS
WITH MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS WERE
BUDGET AND SCHEDULE CONSTRAINTS
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY FOUR
PROVIDES A PATHWAY FOR LIMITED
APPLICATION AND WILL IMPROVE THE
ABILITY OF THE COUNTY TO DELIVER
SPECIFIC PROJECTS WITH GREATER
SUCCESS.
COUNTY SIMPLY DESIRE THE ABILITY
TO USE THE RIGHT TOOL FOR THE
RIGHT JOB AND THIS BILL GIVES
ORANGE COUNTY ANOTHER TOOL IN
ITS TOOL BOX.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I
WANNA A PARTICULARLY THANK STAFF
FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK AND
COMMITTEE STAFF AND AND HELPING
US.
DEVELOPED THE SPELL IT TOOK A
LOT OF WORK AND OUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE.
THE TIME AND ENERGY THAT WAS
SPENT I AM I ABLE TO SAY THAT AT
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE AND JUST SAY THAT THIS
IS A WILL BE AN ESTIMATED COST
SAVINGS OF TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE COUNTY. AND.
WERE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
EFFORTS AND ARCHER YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND.
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
NICOLE MORTAL MEN ON BEHALF OF
THE DESIGN BUILD INSTITUTE OF
AMERICA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU A SCENE NO OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ARE THEIR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
WILL GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
I THINK WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY UN NO COMMENT SO I JUST
WANTED TO SAY.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. KNOW IT HELPS TO
SPEED DELIVERY AND ELIMINATE
SOME REDUNDANCIES AND HELP WITH
COST.
SAW THE CHAIR ALSO HAS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SO WITH THAT.
AUTHORS CLOSING.
I JUST  RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
GIVE A.
DO A ROLL CALL PLEASE THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR CURRY WALDRON. WALDRON
AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CABALLERO
CABALLERO AYE COOLEY GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
STONE.
STONE I'VE VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO THANK
YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS THINK IF.
THAT'S THE WILL START.
OUT WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL GYRO.
WILL START WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE
A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THE SENATE CLEARWATER. THE SAT
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
WATER AGENCIES IN THE STATE.
MANAGING WATER SUPPLY GROUND
WATER FLOOD CONTROL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP.
FOR A DIVERSE JURISDICTION THE
SILICON VALLEY HOME TO NEARLY
TWO MILLION PEOPLE. I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
NINE WHICH AMENDS THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT ACT
TO MAKE THREE IMPORTANT REFORMS.
FIRST IT REFORMS A PARCEL TAX
EXEMPTION PROCESS FOR LOW INCOME
SENIORS BASICALLY EACH YEAR
ABOUT TEN PERCENT OF SENIOR LOW
INCOME TAXPAYERS FAILED TO
RETURN THEIR ANNUAL INCOME
VERIFICATION. FOR A LOCAL PARCEL
TAX EXEMPTION DESPITE NUMEROUS
NOTICES ENCOURAGED THEM
ENCOURAGING THEM. TO RE VERIFY
THEIR STATUS THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ALREADY BEEN VERIFIED
ITS LOW INCOME.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE
CLARIFIES THAT THE DISTRICT NEED
ONLY VERIFY LOW INCOME STATUS
ONCE. AND THE TAXPAYERS
ELIGIBILITY FOR THAT EXEMPTION
MAY REMAIN IN EFFECT UNTIL THE
DISTRICT IS NOTIFIED OF A CHANGE
IN ELIGIBILITY.
SECONDLY IT REFORMS A DISTRICT
BOARD OF DIRECTORS DUTIES AND
MEETING ALLOWANCE
THIS BILL INCREASES THE NUMBER
OF MEETING DAYS FOR WHICH A
DIRECTOR IS ELIGIBLE FOR
REMUNERATION. FROM UP TO TEN
DAYS PER MONTH UP TO TWENTY DAYS
PER MONTH REFLECTING THE ACTUAL
NUMBER OF WORKING DAYS REQUIRED
FOR THE POSITION.
BECAUSE THE MEETING ALLOW IT IS
CURRENTLY CAPTIVE TEN DAYS PER
MONTH DIRECTORS MUST OFTEN WORK
LONG HOURS WITHOUT REMUNERATION
THIS MEANS THAT ONLY PEOPLE WHO
CAN REALISTICALLY SERVE ON THE
BORDER EITHER RETIRED OR
INDEPENDENTLY WEALTHY.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE WILL
ENABLE DIRECTORS TO MORE FULLY
DEDICATE THEMSELVES TO THE
INCREASED NUMBER AND EXPANDING
SCOPE OF THE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE OFFICE.
WELL IT WILL ALSO INCREASE THE
CAPACITY OF DIRECTORS TO PROVIDE
MORE PUBLIC OVERSIGHT OF THE
DISTRICT WATER SUPPLY FLOOD
CONTROL GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS. FOR THE NEARLY TWO
MILLION PEOPLE. AND LASTLY THE
BILL REFORMS DISTRICTS DISTRICT
BOARD VACANCY APPOINTMENTS IT
WILL ENSURE APPROPRIATE
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATION BY
REQUIRING THE APART APPOINTMENT
TO A VACANT BIRD SEED BE MADE
FROM THE GEOGRAPHIC DISTRICT. IN
WHICH THE VACANCY EXISTS RATHER
THAN ANYWHERE FROM SANTA CLARA
COUNTY.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN I WILL
ENSURE APPROPRIATE COMMUNITY
BASED GOVERNMENTS FOR A LARGE
DISTRICT
THAT MANAGES. EVERYTHING HAVING
TO DO WITH WATER IN THE SILICON
VALLEY AND ALL OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS
RACHEL GIPSON DEPUTY
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER FOR
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT.
AND SHE'S HERE FOR ANY QUESTION
MICHAEL QUESTIONS AND RICHARD
SANTOS CHAIR OF THE SENATE CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT.
MAKE COMMENTS GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL AND WILL
STAND UP ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU REVENUE AND.
MADAM CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A RICHER SETTLES.
AS CHAIR OF THE CYCLE VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT ARE JUST SUPPORT
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE.
THANK THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PARA CARES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
AND DOUBLE A CP IN SUPPORT.
GIVE.
HI ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF COMMITTEE
COMMENTS.
NO.
OF WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
A.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS A
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SO CLOSING COMMENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS ADWARE CURRY
WALDRON WALDRON AYE BLOOM. BLOOM
AYE CABALLERO CUPBEARER AYE
COOLEY GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY STONE. VOEPEL
OH. VOEPEL AYE.
IT IS NOT.
THE BILL ITSELF FIVE ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER'S WIFE SALINAS.
CAN THE WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
SEVEN A. B. TWO TWO FIVE EIGHT
ALSO WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CABALLERO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
FIRST LET ME. AT.
EXCEPT THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN OFFERED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
CONSISTENT WITH A
RECOMMENDATION MADE IN THE TWO
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION REPORT. AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY EIGHT WOULD
PROVIDE AUGHED THOSE ARE LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSIONS
WITH A ONE TIME SMALL INFUSION
OF GRANT LIKE MONIES TO FOCUS
EFFORTS ON STREAMLINING
STREAMLINING LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND IMPROVING EFFICIENCY IN
SERVICE DELIVERY. THERE IS A
NEED FOR LOVE GOES TO CONDUCT IN
DEPTH STUDIES OF LOCAL AGENCY
SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT COULD
RESULT IN MORE OPTIONS FOR
GREATER EFFICIENCIES. THE
ELIMINATION OF NON FICTION THESE
ORGANIZATIONS OR REORGANIZATION
ACTIONS.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY EIGHT WOULD
ESTABLISH A GRANT LIKE FUNDING
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL.
TO PROVIDE LAUGHED BECAUSE WITH
FUNDING TO CONDUCT STUDIES AND
ANALYSES OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND SERVICES. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF STREAMLINING THE
LIVERY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICES.
THROUGH TWENTY AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY EIGHT LAST POST WOULD BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS KNOWN SERVICE
AND GOVERNANCE CONCERNS THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY SAVE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS MONEY.
GRANT FUNDS WILL BE USED
SPECIFICALLY TAKEN SPECIAL TO
CONDUCT SPECIAL STUDIES TO
IDENTIFY AND SUPPORT
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE GREATER
EFFICIENCIES AND TO POTENTIALLY
INITIALLY INITIATE ACTIONS BASED
ON THE STUDIES. THAT REMOVE OR
REDUCE LOCAL COSTS
THAT'S INCENTIVIZING LOCAL
AGENCIES TO WORK WITH A LOT GOES
IN DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
REORGANIZATION PLANS.
THE GRANT WOULD SUNSET ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE.
THE BILL ALSO CHANGES THE
PROTEST THRESHOLD FOR LAUGH
BECAUSE INITIATED ACTIONS SOLELY
FOR THE PURPOSES OF ACTIONS
FUNDED THROUGH THE GRANT THE
PROTEST THRESHOLD WOULD BE
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. RATHER THAN
TEN PERCENT.
FOR THE NARROW SCOPE OF PURPOSES
OF THIS GRANT.
AND FOR THE LIMITED TIME THAT IT
IS IN PLACE AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
WOULD SIMPLY MER EXISTING
STATUTE FOR BOH DISILLUSIONED
AND OTHER CHANGES EVERY
ORGANIZATION.
IF I LAUGHED COKE INITIATES
ACTION OUTSIDE OF THIS GRANT
PROGRAM THEY'RE SUBJECT TO THE
EXISTING TEN PERCENT.
WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS SUPERVISOR
JOHN LEOPOLD COUNTY OF SANTA
CRUZ AND PAMELA MILLER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION
COMMISSIONS.
THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
LEOPOLD A MEMBER THE SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
CHAIR OF THE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
LOCAL. AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSION AND BOARD MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LAUGH GOES. WANNA THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO LIST MY
TESTIMONY IN YOUR FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB TWO TWO FIVE
EIGHT. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABALLERO.
FOR AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON FOR CO AUTHORING.
A OVER MY TEN YEARS ON OUR
COUNTIES LAUGHTER WE'VE DONE A
NUMBER OF MUNICIPAL SERVICE
REVIEWS OR M. SR'S. THAT HAVE
POINTED TO AREAS WHERE SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO GAIN EFFICIENCIES
AND SERVICE.
A ABOUT A DOZEN YEARS AGO WE
USED ALL OF OUR SPECIAL STUDY
FUNDS TO LOOK AT FIRE DISTRICTS
COUNTY WIDE AT A COST OF NEARLY
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. ARE STUDY POINTED TO
AREAS WERE CONSOLIDATION OF
SERVICES ARE MERGERS MIGHT MAKE
SENSE TO IMPROVE THE FINANCIAL
PICTURE IN THE LONG TERM
VIABILITY OF SERVICES. THAT WE
HELD HEARINGS WHEN PRESENTED TO
EVERY FIRE DISTRICT AND FOUND
THAT NONE OF THE FIRE DISTRICT
EVEN WHEN PRESENTED WITH THIS
INFORMATION WERE INTERESTED IN
MAKING THE ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGES TO THE DISTRICT.
AND OUR LAST ROUND OF MS OURS WE
DID NOT INTEND TO DO A DETAILED
STUDY OF EACH FIRE DISTRICT
GIVEN THE RESPONSE THAT WE HAD
PREVIOUSLY RECEIVED. BUT UNLIKE
BEFORE ONE OF THE DISTRICT TOLD
US THEY WERE READY TO SERIOUSLY
LOOK AT THESE ISSUES. WE REACHED
OUT TO THE NEIGHBORING FIRE
DISTRICT AND FOUND INSERTS
INTEREST THERE AS WELL. AT LEAST
ONE BOARD WAS READY AND BOTH
FIRE DISTRICT HAD JUST LET GO OF
THEIR FIRE CHIEFS
PRESENTING A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
CLEAR HURDLES THAT USUALLY STAND
IN THE WAY OF THESE DISCUSSIONS.
WE HAD GOOD INTEREST BUT LOW
FUNDS TO CONDUCT A STUDY THAT
COULD LEAD TO BETTER SERVICES
AND FINANCIAL STABILITY FOR EACH
OF THE FIRE DISTRICTS.
A PART OF THE REASONS THAT FIRE
DISTRICTS WERE INTERESTED WAS
DUE TO THEIR INCREASING COST
REGION OPERATIONS. ARE LOCAL
LASKO HOWEVER HAD SPENT MOST OF
OUR SPECIAL STUDY REVENUE
LOOKING AT PARKS AND SANITATION
DISTRICT SO WE FACED A
CROSSROADS. IF WE HAD A GRANT
PROGRAM LIKE THE ONE ENVISIONED
IT AB TWO TWO FIVE EIGHT THE
CHOICE WOULD HAVE BEEN CLEAR.
THROUGH A SUCCESSFUL
APPLICATION WE COULD STUDY THE
ISSUES OF INFRASTRUCTURE SERVICE
DLIVERY SALARY AND BENEFITS
PARITY AND LONG TERM PERSONNEL
BENEFITS.
A STUDY LIKE THIS WOULD COST
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND WOULD TAX THE
BUDGETS OF ALL THREE AGENCIES.
OF THE TOP REASONS THAT LAUGH GO
DO NOT INITIATE THE ACTIONS TO
IMPROVE SERVICES THE LACK OF
FUNDING ALWAYS FEATURES
PROMINENTLY. IN FACT FORTY SIX
PERCENT OF LEFT GOES HAVE AN
ANNUAL BUDGET OF UNDER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO YOU CAN SEE WHAT A FINANCIAL
IMPACT THESE KINDS OF STUDIES
HAVE ON LAUGH GOES.
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
RARELY RECOMMENDS FUNDING TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS BUT FORTUNATELY
THEY SAW THAT A SMALL ONETIME
INFUSION OF ONE MILLION TO THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANT FUNDING
POTENTIALLY COULD SAVE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ADDITIONAL
MONEY. IF IT LEADS TO A
STREAMLINED LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
IMPROVED EFFICIENCY IN SERVICE
DELIVERY.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS WE HAVE
SEEN THE LEGISLATURE HAS
SOMETIMES BEEN FRUSTRATED WITH
THE SLOW DELIBERATE OF WACKO
PROCESSES AND INTRODUCED BILLS
THAT WOULD TAKE AWAY THE LOCAL
ANALYSIS OF ISSUES. TEST IS THE
CONSOLIDATION OF SPECIAL
DISTRICTS
TODAY I ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR A
BI TWO TWO FIVE EIGHT TO PROVIDE
THE ONLY FUNDING WE WOULD GET
FOR THE STATE TO CONDUCT OUR
STATE MANDATED. RESPONSIBILITIES
AND HELP CONDUCT THE STUDIES AND
IMPROVED EFFICIENCIES OF SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THROUGH THIS LEGISLATION WE
HAVE.
WE KEEP DECISIONS MADE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WHICH IS THE BEST
PLACE TO RESOLVE COMPLICATED
ISSUES OF MERGERS AND
CONSOLIDATION. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PAMELA MILLER WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LAUGH
BECAUSE.
AND I'M A WILL TRY TO BE VERY
BRIEF HERE AND I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR ALL
OF THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. AS
WELL AS THE.
COMMITTEE STAFF FOUR OF THEIR
VARYING PERSPECTIVES AND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON FOR CO
AUTHORING THINK YOU.
THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS ALL TOO
WELL A YOU'VE SEEN WAY TOO MANY
OF BILLS OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
THAT.
BYPASS LAUGH CHO OR.
DIFFER OUR AUTHORITY. AND OTHER
SQUARE UNDER GROWING CRITICISM
FOR NOT INITIATING ACTION TO
CREATE GREATER EFFICIENCIES OR
TO ADDRESS EXISTING LOCAL
ISSUES.
IN THE PROVISION OF DELIVERING
SERVICES.
BUT THERE IS ACTION BEING TAKEN
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND WHILE
THERE IS THERE'S IT'S VERY CLEAR
THAT MORE CAN BE DONE. A A
RECENT STUDY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
SURVEY EVER MEMBERS INDICATES
THAT THERE WERE FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE DETERMINATIONS. MADE%
IN MSR IS RELATING TO A FUTURE
CHANGE OF ORGANIZATION OR RE
ORG.
AND OF THOSE AGENCIES INITIATED
ACTION TWENTY ONE PERCENT OF THE
TIME AND LAUGH KOS ONLY EIGHT
PERCENT.
THERE ARE SEVERAL PRIMARY
IMPEDIMENTS THAT LAUGH BECAUSE
FACE TO TAKING ACTION.
POLITICAL WILL WHICH ENCOMPASSES
THE LAUGH CHO COMMISSION AND THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS BOARDS
ABILITIES TO MAKE THOSE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS IS ONE OF
THOSE IMPEDIMENTS.
POLITICAL WELL ON THE LAUGH CHO
PART ALSO ENCOMPASSES A LACK OF
FINANCIAL RESOURCES WHICH YOU'VE
JUST HEARD ABOUT. AS WELL AS THE
CONTRAST IN LEVEL OF PROTEST
THRESHOLD.
THE BILL ANALYSIS SITE SOME
LAUGH CHO BUDGET DATA SUPERVISOR
LEOPOLD JUSTIN AND THE REALITY
IS THAT WHEN YOU'RE BUDGET YOUR
ANNUAL BUDGET IS UNDER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND YOU HAVE AN ANNUAL WORK PLAN
YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW WITH ALL
THESE.
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS TO MEET.
YOUR SOURCE OF REVENUE IS VERY
HIGHLY LIMITED THERE IS LITTLE
TO NO ROOM TO TAKE AN IN DEPTH
LOOK AT SERVICE AREAS WHERE THEY
CAN UP. AND WHERE FISHING SEIZE
CAN BE GAINED.
SERVICE EFFICIENCIES THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY PROVIDE A MORE
STREAMLINED AND COST EFFECTIVE
WAY OF DELIVERING QUALITY
MUNICIPAL SERVICES.
AND LITTLETON NO ROOM TO TAKE
ACTION.
SO WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION REPORT AND
THEIR RECOMMENDATION FOR THIS
ONE TIME GRANT FUNDING.
ANOTHER RECOMMENDATION THAT THEY
MADE AND ONE THAT WE AGREE WITH
IS TO TAKE AN IN DEPTH LOOK AT
THE HUGELY DISPIRITO TEST
PROVISIONS.
THE LEVELS ARE ARBITRARY AND
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER FOR A LAUGH
CHO INITIATED ACTION.
WHICH CAME ABOUT IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE WHEN LAUGH BECAUSE
WE'RE ACTUALLY GIVEN THE POWER
TO INITIATE ACTION.
AS I MENTIONED THIS IS ONE OF
THE TOP THREE REASONS WHY LAUGH
BECAUSE ACTUALLY DO NOT INITIATE
ACTION.
THIS BILL ALLOWS THOSE ACTIONS
ONLY DURING THAT FIVE YEAR
PERIOD AND ONLY PERTAINING TO
THIS PROGRAM. TO MERE EXISTING
STATUTE AT IT IN TERMS OF THOSE
THRESHOLDS.
SOME MAY ARGUE THAT IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE TO RAISE THE
PROTESTS THRESHOLD WITHOUT A
LONG STUDY. AND THAT WE HAVE
INSUFFICIENT DATA TO SUPPORT
SUCH AN ACTION AT THIS TIME. BUT
WE BELIEVE RAISING THE THRESHOLD
TO THE SAME LEVEL AS NON LAUGH
CHO INITIATED PROCESSES.
PRESERVES THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO
PROTEST.
AND THEY HAVE THEIR VOICE HEARD.
WE'VE HAD TWENTY FIVE YEARS
TWENTY FIVE YEARS WITH THE
PROTESTS LEVELS AT TEN PERCENT.
TODAY WE'RE ASKING ONLY FOR A
LIMITED CHANGE FOR A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME AND ON A VERY
LIMITED NUMBER OF ACTIONS.
AT AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL
YEARLY ALREADY INDICATED IT ONLY
APPLIES TO POTENTIAL ACTIONS
TAKEN PURSUANT TO THIS GRANT
PROGRAM. AND THIS GRANT PROGRAM
IS DESIGNED FOR LEFT GOES TO
ADDRESS KNOWN SERVICE AND
GOVERNANCE CONCERNS IDENTIFIED
IN A PREVIOUS MSR.
CALLASPO EDITING GAUGING IN A
BROAD LONG TERM STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATION ABOUT CLEANING UP
THE ENTIRE PROTEST PROCESS.
BUT FEEL THAT THE TIME IS RIGHT
NOW TO MOVE FORWARD.
THIS BILL IS A GOOD STEP IN
PROVIDING LAUGHED BECAUSE THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO DO IT THOSE
LEGISLATURE HAS ASKED OF THEM.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER MEMBER PAT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE CALIFORNIA SPEAK USE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT ALSO FOR MY COLLEAGUE
WITH URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU I DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
I'M ANTHONY CAN HELP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION AND WE HAVE A
CONCERNS POSITION.
HOW FIRST OFF A WE'D ORDINARILY
BE IN SUPPORT OF A MEASURE LIKE
THIS?
THE PORTENT WORK LAUGHTER DIES.
I CLEARLY UNDERFUNDED.
AND WE DO SUPPORT THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION RECOMMENDATION
THAT'S KIND OF THE GENESIS OF
THIS MEASURE.
HOW WE THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP? ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ISSUES.
HOWEVER RESPECTFULLY AND
REGRETTABLY OUR MEMBERS DON'T
FEEL THAT THIS IS THE CORRECT
VEHICLE TO ADD ANY NEW.
PROTEST THRESHOLD.
I AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER BY
MY.
A FRIEND'S A LAUGH CHO THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION ALSO
RECOMMENDED THE LEGISLATURE TAKE
UP.
MORE COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE
PROTEST THRESHOLDS.
AND TO THAT IN OUR MEMBERS ARE
REALLY EAGER TO PARTICIPATE IN
SUCH A STUDY. POWER BUT WE DO
FEAR THAT ADDING THIS NEW
THRESHOLD TIED TO THE GRANT
FUNDING. WOULD JUST COMPLICATE
THIS EFFORT SO.
AGAIN WE WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
CONTINUE LEADERSHIP. AND WITH
THE FOUR TO WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS HOW BUT WE WE DO
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT
TYING.
YET ANOTHER THRESHOLD.
I TO A GRANT.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ON MY
CONCERNS.
HIS ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION YEAH I'M SO I
JUST GOT.
WE ALREADY HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND.
WHICH I TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
IN RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WE ARE CURRY.
AYE AGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO. CABALLERO AYE
COOLEY GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO STONE.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO.
IT.
FOR ME.
WE NEED ONE MORE VOTE THANK YOU.
I SHOULD.
I LIKE THAT TOGETHER UMP THE
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO AN ENTERTAINER.
SALUTE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY I MISSED AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON IS THE
SECOND.
SO WE HAVE A.
LACKEY.
OKAY.
ADWARE CURRY. ADWARE CURRY AYE
WALDRON BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO.
COME HERE I CAN COOLEY GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE
STONE VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE.
I. WAS LOOKING.
THIS ACCOUNT HAS BEEN APPROVAL
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
PEN AB TWENTY SEVEN ELEVEN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHEN WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM.
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE FOR
COUNTY'S LARGEST INCOME SOURCE
THAT COVERS THE COST OF THE
CENTRAL. DISCRETIONARY AMENDED
PROGRAMS
IT IS USED TO FUND CRITICAL
SERVICES LIKE PUBLIC SAFETY
COURTS HEALTH CARE HOME ONCE
MENTAL ILLNESS PROGRAMS. AND
SOCIAL SERVICES FOR COUNTIES
NEEDIEST AND MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS.
ORANGE COUNTY RECEIVES THE
LOWEST PERCENTAGE OF PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE THAN ANY COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA. BOTH SIX CENTS TO
ONE DOLLAR THIS FOR THE FOR THE
FOR DISTRIBUTING LOCAL PROPERTY
TAXES HAS NOT CHANGED SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
NORTH COUNTY WE CONTRIBUTE MORE
TO RECEIVE LESS THAN ARE PURE
COUNTIES.
FOR EXAMPLE SEVENTY COUNTY SHARE
IS TEN CENTS ALAMEDA AND
STANDARD RECEIVES ABOUT TWELVE
CENTS.
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY RECEIVES
TWENTY ONE CENTS ON THE DOLLAR.
BUT ANOTHER WAY ORANGE COUNTY
SENDS ABOUT NINERS HE SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS MORE EACH
YEAR AND FUNDING TO THE STATE
RECEIVES FOREIGNERS AND FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS LESS THAN THE
AVERAGE OF THE TOP FIFTEEN
COUNTIES. KEEP HIM ON THE ORANGE
COUNTY THE THIRD MOST POPULOUS
IN THE STATE. WITH A POPULATION
OF MORE THAN THREE POINT THREE
MILLION RESIDENTS.
WITH ALL THAT BEING SAID AB
TWENTY SOME MONEY WILL BE MONIS
INCREMENTAL STEP TOWARD BRING
THAT PROPERTY TAX REIMBURSEMENT.
OF THREE MORE PROPER LEVEL FOR
ORANGE COUNTY AND.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE COUNTY
TO KEEP ANY PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
THAT THEY HAVE LEFT OVER FROM
PAYING THE STATE.
THAT MONEY WOULD STAY WITH THE
COUNTY RESET THE BASE
BY TAKING SLOW LONG TERM
APPROACH.
THIS WILL ALLOW THE COUNTY TO
EVENTUALLY RAISES BASED TO
TWELVE CENTS
WHICH BRINGS US UP TO SAY NO TO
COUNTIES AND LEVEL.
WITH ME TODAY IS MARCELINO
SUPERVISING DEPUTY COUNTY
COUNSEL THE COUNTY OF ORANGE
WILL PROVIDE SOME SPECIFIC
INFORMATION AND TO ANSWER. ANY
QUESTIONS THEY MAY HAVE.
WELL I DON'T. THINK IT'S GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF MY
NOSE MARK SABINO. PIE AB TWO
SEVEN ONE ONE GRADUALLY CHEESE
PROPERTY TAX EQUITY FOR THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE BY. INCREASING
THE COUNTY'S SHARE OF COUNTY
WIDE AD VALOREM PROPERTY TAX.
REVENUES OVER TIME UNTIL THE
COUNTY'S SHARE REACHES TWELVE
PERCENT
OUR ORANGE COUNTY SHARE PROPERTY
TAXES ONLY INCREASES.
DURING YEARS WERE PROBABLY TAX
GROWTH IS GREATER THAN THREE
PERCENT SO IT'S DESIGNED TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF THIS
GRADUAL INCREASE OVER TIME.
WELL ONCE A COUNTY SHARE REACHES
TWELVE PERCENT THE COUNTY SHARE
NO LONGER INCREASES AND WILL
REMAIN CONSTANT.
OF AB AB TWO SEVEN ONE ONE
PROPOSES THE ADDITION OF REVENUE
TAXATION CODE NINE SEVEN POINT
EIGHT ZERO. AND I THINK POINT
EIGHT ZERO IS ACTUALLY THE BILL
THAT THERE WAS PREVIOUSLY A NINE
SEVEN POINT EIGHT ZERO THAT WAS
SPONSORED BY.
LUKE RHEA IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
AND.
OUR BILL IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
LOOK AT IT IT'S IT'S VERY
SIMILAR IN TERMS OF STRUCTURE.
ARE.
AB TO SET. THE PREVIOUS NINE
SEVEN POINT EIGHT ZERO.
.
EIGHT OPERATED IN THIS BILL
OPERATES BY.
.
INCREASING BY INCREASING.
THE THE COUNTIES AB EIGHT ARE.
INCREASINGLY KINDS PROBABLY
TEXTURE BY THE COUNTY EQUITY
AMOUNT
AND THAT COUNTY EQUITY AMOUNT IS
THEN.
DECREASED FROM THE COUNTY ERA.
OR.
FROM THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY.
FIVE D. ERA OF THE AMOUNT OF THE
COUNTY EQUITY NOW WE SET THAT
ONE PERCENT OF ERA WHICH IS
PROBABLY ABOUT SEVENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS.
BY THE VERY NEXT YEAR STARTS
OFTEN THAT BASES ITS STATE IT IT
CONTINUES AND AFTER THAT BASS
THING GROWS WITH A ASSESSED
PROPERTY VALUES. BUT THEN IF THE
PROPERTY TAX.
.
THE PROPERTY TAX ASSESSED VALUE
RATE IS IS GREATER THAN THREE
PERCENT. THEN YOU ALSO ADDED THE
AMOUNT OVER THREE PERCENT TO
THAT BATES.
SO OVER TIME IT WILL GRADUALLY
INCREASE IN AGAIN GET TO TWELVE
GET TO TWELVE PERCENT.
ARE YOU MIGHT ASK WHY IS A
TWELVE PERCENT CHOSEN AS A
BIGGER IT IS IT IS THE SAME RATE
AS OF THIS AS THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO WHICH IS SIMILAR. BOTH
GEOGRAPHICALLY.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS BY POPULATION.
POPULATION OF OVER THREE
MILLION OF PEOPLE. OF.
AGAIN A. B. AB TWO SEVEN ONE ONE
BY ADS ADS READY IN TEXAS COULD
NINE SEVEN POINT EIGHT ZERO. OF
NINETEEN POINT EIGHT MIND SEVEN
POINT EIGHT ZERO.
WAS.
THERE WAS A BILL THAT PROVIDED
PROPERTY TAX EQUITY FOR ORANGE
COUNTY ARE IT WAS.
REPEALED IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AS PART OF THE FIX FOR.
THE.
FOR AS PART OF THE FIX OF THE
TAKE A VLF MONIES FROM ORANGE
COUNTY WHERE. IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN ORANGE COUNTY FIT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WAS.
TAKEN AWAY FROM ORANGE COUNTY
BY VIRTUE OF THE PASSAGE OF SB
EIGHTY NINE SO. OF THIS WHAT
THIS DOES IS THAT THIS RE
INTRODUCE A PROPERTY TAX EQUITY
FOR ORANGE COUNTY IT DOES SO IN
A GRADUAL MANNER DESIGNED TO
BRING IT UP TO TWELVE PERSON.
WITH THAT IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
WELCOME.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AMY JENKINS
ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL IN SUPPORT THINK
IF.
YOU.
THE OTHER WITNESSES SAYING THEN
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE. COMMITTEE.
YES AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU.
SO.
THE THING ABOUT A FIX PROPERTY
TAX BY A YEAR AND YOU'RE RELYING
ON AND
SORT OF AN INCREMENT OF
FINANCING IS GO SOME IS A CHEN
WHO'S. IF.
THIS MOVES FORWARD WHO WHOSE
LOSING OUT OF THE SIX BY.
BOB THANK YOU SHOW FOR MY
QUESTIONS SO AS WE SAID BEFORE
THIS WOULD HAVE REDUCTION TO THE
READ THE ROUGH HOWEVER IT WOULD
BE OFFSET WITH.
GENERAL FUND IN THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
DISCUSSING FURTHER ON.
OKAY SETS US THAT WOULD GENERAL
FUNDS BUT I NOTICED THAT THE
BILL. IS IS PROTECTING SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND NOT
NECESSARILY OTHER SO WHAT ABOUT
BASIC EIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
MITCHELL VETO IT WOULD YES A
BASIC EX BASS GATE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DON'T RECEIVE ARE FOR
EXAMPLE WEB WHEN YOU'RE A CITY.
IRVINE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS I THINK A ONE OF IS THE ONLY
BE SICK EIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE. THEY DON'T
RECEIVE EUROPE I PURCHASE A FACT
THAT THERE IS THAT THEIR BASIC
QUE SO DOES SO THE TAKE. THAT
THE DEDUCTION OF MONIES FROM YOU
RALPH.
WOULD NOT AFFECT THEM.
OKAY
THAT THE ISSUE THAT I HAVE WITH
THIS AND I'M NOT I'M NOT GOING
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. THAT
PROP THIRTEEN WAS IN ARTFULLY
DOWN IN AND PUT IN PLACE A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO.
WE'VE HAD THAT THEN.
DO PROP NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE
WHICH LEADS TO HEREAFTER THE
TROUBLE FLIPS TO TO A NUMBER OF
FINANCING MECHANISMS THAT HAVE
HAD TO MOVE. MONEY AROUND AND
THE FACT TO ME THAT ORANGE
COUNTY IS ARTIFICIALLY LOW WAS
REALLY BASED ON DECISIONS OF THE
COUNTY. YEARS AGO AND IF WE'RE
GOING TO START TO OPEN UP HOW WE
FINANCE AND HOW WE MANAGE
PROPERTY TAXES I THINK WE HAVE
TO LOOK ACROSS EQUITABLY.
ACROSS THE STATE IVAN NUMBER
CITY CENTER LOW WELL CITIES THAT
THAT ARE ALSO STRUGGLING IN NEXT
CALCULATIONS BECAUSE HE OF OF
HISTORICALLY HOW IT WAS PUT
TOGETHER SO I THINK WE HAVE A
MUCH BIGGER PROBLEM THAN.
AND.
I'M NOT SURE IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
GO IN ONE PIECE AT A TIME AND
TRY AND SOLVE.
ONE COUNTIES PROBLEMS ESPECIALLY
AT THE EXPENSE OF THE GENERAL
FUND WHEN WHEN WE DON'T
NECESSARILY KNOW.
HOW THAT'S GOING TO WORK ON WHAT
THAT'S GOING TO MEAN AND BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE? A BROADER WAY OF
APPROACHING THIS ISSUE WITH ALL
OF THE OTHER LOW WEALTH.
CITIES AND.
AND JURISDICTIONS THAT THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO DEAL WITH SO I I'M
REALLY LOW THEN WE SHOULD BE
VERY CAREFUL CHERRY PICKING.
AWAY AT SOMETHING THAT'S GOING
TO HAVE AN IMPACT HERE
POTENTIALLY IMPACT.
DOWN THE LINE WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING HOW WE AS A STATE
OR HAVE A STRATEGY ON HOW WE
PROVIDE SOME EQUITY ACROSS THE
BOARD BECAUSE WHAT PROP THIRTEEN
THE WAY IT LOCKED DOWN IN THE
WAY IT. WENT LOCKED DOWN THE
PROPERTY TAX IN THE WAY THAT
COUNTIES AND CITIES RECEIVE
REVENUE THERE THERE'S TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF INEQUITIES ACROSS
INCLUDING IN SCHOOL FINANCING
AND SO I DON'T THINK IT'S QUITE
AS SIMPLE AS.
IT'S JUST THE STATE'S GENERAL
FUND THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
LOSER HERE I THINK POTENTIALLY
IN SOME OF THE CALCULATIONS IT
HAS IMPLICATIONS ON ON OTHER
DISTRICTS AND I AND I THINK THIS
IS. NOT AN APPROPRIATE STEP TO
TAKE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
WILL COMMITTEE.
YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I I.
WANT TO APPLAUD YOU.
FOR ADDRESSING AN ISSUE THAT IS
HUGE I WERE EXPERIENCING THE
SAME THING.
ESPECIALLY WITH SOME SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE BEING HUGELY.
SHORTED.
THAT NEED THE SUPPORT HOWEVER I
DO SURE.
SENTIMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER STONE ON. JUST HITTING
THE NAIL ON THE HEAD AND THAT
THIS IS A MUCH BROADER.
ISSUE THAN JUST A DISTRICT AND
IT REALLY NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
AND IN A MORE HOLISTIC WAY AND.
I IF YOU DO THE WORD USED THE
WORD PIECEMEAL BUT FOR LACK OF
ANY OTHER WORD RIGHT NOW TO JUST
TRY TO DO IT ONE LITTLE. AT A
TIME IS IS A BIT PROBLEMATIC.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE START TURNING
TO THE GENERAL FUND TO BE THE
BACKFILL.
BECAUSE IT'S EASY TO SAY ALL
WITH THE GENERAL FUNDS GOING TO
DO THIS BUT THEN. WHEN THE
GENERAL FUND TAKES AHEAD AND IT
IS GOING TO TAKE A HIT. THERE'S
SOMEBODY THAT'S GOING TO.
BE SHORTER BECAUSE THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT I BELIEVE IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY DO HAVE
THAT PROTECTION OF PROP NINETY
EIGHT SO THERE'S GONNA BE
SOMETHING. THAT'S GOING TO
EXPERIENCE THAT SHORTAGE IF IT'S
IF WE'RE DEPENDING ON THE
GENERAL FUND TO DO THE BACKFILL
SO.
TODAY I I'M NOT GONNA.
SAY NO ON IT BUT I AM PROBABLY
NOT GONNA GO UP ON IT AS WELL
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE NEED A MOTION.
THE MOVE.
MY MOTION IS SUCKED.
I HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
VOEPEL.
I WILL SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
WITH WITH THE RESERVATION OF
WHAT IT HAPPENS ON COMES THE
FLOOR I TOO AM CONCERNED WITH
THE SAME THINGS PICKED YOU
SMILING AT.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HOPEFULLY FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT.
BECAUSE IT IS A REALLY
FRUSTRATING. THINGS HAPPEN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO LET'S SEE IF YOU CAN COME UP
WITH A MIRACLE BUT I WILL
RESERVE MY RIGHT THAT ON THE
ROUTE FOR THAT I MEAN NATIONAL
FOR THEN SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR APPRECIATE
THAT IF A MATTRESS ASSIGNMENTS
OF MR SOUNDS TO GRAYSON. FROM
AND WE BELIEVE THAT'S OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO GET EQUITY
FOR ONE SPECIFIC COUNTY AND I
CERTAINLY WILL REAP REMEMBER
THAT.
RESENTMENTS ABOUT BACK IN THE
WITH GENERAL FUND AND SEE
THERE'S A WAY WE CAN. ARMS GO
AROUND ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
I'LL TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES.
I RESPECT ESCRIBIR GOOD
DIFFICULT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS HIM
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
pAGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM NOT VOTING CABALLERO.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE STONE.
STONE NO VOEPEL. REPEL I.
THE.
WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT FOR
ADDITIONAL OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRETTY MANAGER.
OKAY NEXT WILL BE AYE A BEAN
TWENTY SEVENTY ONE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
THIS A DO PASS RICARDO.
YOU NEED SOME.
WELCOME. GOOD. AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS.
IN THAT TWENTY SIXTEEN I
AUTHORED AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
NINE WHICH WAS A BILL THAT EASED
AND STREAMLINE THE NUMBER OF
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE BUILDING OF
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS ARE.
GRANNY FLAT SINCE ARE COMMONLY
KNOWN AND SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
THAT BILL WE HAVE SEEN AN
EXPLOSION OF PERMITS FOR EIGHTY
IS ACROSS THE STATE. SOME CITIES
ARE STILL IN THE DARK ON THE NEW
RULES WERE WORKING ON THAT ISSUE
OTHERS. HAVE FAT DRAG THEIR FEET
AND UPDATING THEIR ORDINANCES
BUT WE'RE. MAKING A DENT IN OUR
HOUSING NEEDS FACTS AB TWENTY
TWO NINE TWENTY TWO NINETY NINE.
HAS LED TO THE PERMITTING OF
MORE THAN FOUR THOUSAND EIGHTY
USE ACROSS THE STATE IN THE
SHORT TIME THAT IT'S BEEN. IN.
A.
LAW NEARLY EIGHTEEN HUNDRED OF
THOSE. HAVE BEEN PERMITTED IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
BUT THERE ARE SOME ISSUES THAT
HAVE ARISEN.
A CURRENT TO A LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER
RULES ALLOW FOR BUILDINGS TO BE
BUILT. IN THAT POWER LINE
EASEMENT.
WHICH IS THE DROP LINE OF.
HIGH VOLTAGE LINES AT AT THE
EDGE OF A PROPERTY. OF.
AND THE A FREQUENTLY THESE POWER
LINES ARE OVER UNINHABITED
BUILDINGS AND THIS RESULTED IN A
TREND OF GARAGES OR RECREATION
ROOMS. BEING BUILT IN THESE
EASEMENTS BUT NO HOUSING.
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES HAS
FOUND THAT SOME OF THESE
BUILDINGS HAVE ALREADY BEEN.
CONVERTED TO HAVE ADULTS
HABITABLE SPACE.
AND THE CITY WANTS TO ENCOURAGE
BOTH NEW CONSTRUCTION AND FOR
OWNERS OF NON PERMITTED
CONVERSIONS TO BRING THESE UNITS
UP TO ALL OF OUR OTHER BUILDING
CODES. TO AID IN PUBLIC SAFETY.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY ONE WILL
REMOVE LIABILITY RELATED TO
UTILITY SYSTEMS FAILURE OR
DAMAGE TO STRUCTURES. BUILT
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT ARE CONVERTED TO
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS AFTER
THAT SAME DAY.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY ONE COULD FREE
UP ANOTHER FOUR HUNDRED TO SIX
HUNDRED PERMITS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY STALLED DO THIS VERY
SPECIFIC AND UNIQUE ISSUE
CONCERNING POWER LINES AND
GARAGE CAN VERSIONS. IN EXISTING
HOMES IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
THE BILL'S LANGUAGE DOES NOT
REMOVE LIABILITY FOR NEW
BUILDINGS THAT ARE BUILT IN
POWER LINE EASEMENTS AFTER
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
WITHOUT THIS CHANGE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO ALLOW THESE
UNITS TO BE CONVERTED. UNLESS
PART OF THE BUILING IS REMOVED
FROM THE EASEMENT AND YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT WOULD AT
SIGNIFICANT COST TO APPLICANTS
AND PROBABLY.
A RESULT IN NO CONVERSIONS TO
RESIDENTIAL USE IN THIS WOULD
DISCOURAGE HOMEOWNERS FROM
SEEKING PERMITS FOR THE EXISTING
NOT PERMITTED CONVERSIONS. ARE
AND WOULD RESULT IN CONTINUATION
OF WHAT ARE CURRENTLY ILLEGAL
STRUCTURES
AND I THINK. THANK YOU AND ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND SYLVIA SO
LEASES HERE FROM THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND DEPARTMENT OF WATER
POWER.
THANK YOU WELL REPRESENTING BUT
SHE'S NOT FROM THOSE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALL BE
BRIEF SYLVIA SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AYE
WE STRONGLY SUPPORTED THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. PRIOR IT
LEGISLATION REGARDING EDIE USE
AS HE NOTED IN HIS TESTIMONY
IT'S BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL WE'VE
RECEIVED ALMOST TWO APPLICATION
THE TWO THOUSAND. APPLICATIONS
FOR CONVERSION OF EXISTING
STRUCTURES.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL HELP
ACCELERATE THAT CONVERSION
PROVIDE BRINGING MORE HOUSING
UNITS ONBOARD WHICH WE
DESPERATELY NEED IN THE CITY SO
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WELCOME.
ATTACK FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SABAH IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. SING ON ANY ONE THAT
OPPOSES.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
YES AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU.
SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL I THINK
THERE'S THAT THE IMMUNITY
PROVISIONS HILL BEEN WORKIN WILL
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION THE NEXT.
BUT AND I LOOK FORWARD TO IT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SO YOU DO HAVE A GOOD WITH LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THE ARC.
EXCESS RETOOLING UNIT BILL
SURPRISED ME IN TERMS OF HOW
SUCCESSFUL IT HAS BEEN.
AT WHAT IS.
UP PERHAPS MOST SATISFYING
ABOUT THE BILL HAVING CARRIED A
LOT OF CONTROVERSIAL HOUSING
LEGISLATION IS THAT THIS IS A
BILL THAT HAS BEEN SUPPORTED BY
BOTH HIM BEES AND NIMBIS. I'M
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL BE IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL
I THINK THIS IS GREAT NEWS
RESTORING GET MORE THESE ONLINE.
A WITHOUT SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL EMOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY AGUIAR CURRY. I'M
AGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON WALDRON
NO BLOOM AYE AYE BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO. COOLEY COOLEY AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE STONE STONE AYE
VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE.
SIXTY ONE THEY BILLS LOOKS LIKE
IT'S UP THERE
OKAY WE'RE GONNA START WITH ITEM
NUMBER SIX.
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
UP FOR ALLOW ME TO PRESENT A. B.
TWENTY TO THIRTY EIGHT TO THAT
THIS IS MY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DISASTER OMNIBUS BILL. AS I'M
CALLING IT.
I CHOSE INTRODUCED ONE BILL WITH
MULTIPLE PROPOSALS IN THE HOPE
OF THE CREATING EXPEDIENT
LEGISLATIVE AT A SOLUTION.
THESE PROPOSALS CAME TO LIGHT
AFTER LAST FALL'S DEVASTATING
FIRES IN MY DISTRICT.
AT THAT POINT IT BECAME CLEAR
THAT THERE WAS A NEED TO UPDATE
SEVERAL OF THE STATUES THAT
AFFECT LOCAL AGENCIES AND HOW WE
PREPARE FOR DISASTERS.
MITIGATE DISASTERS AN ACCOUNT
FOR DISASTERS AFTER THE FACT.
THIS BILL REQUIRES LAUGH KOS IN
THE LIST OF FACTORS THEY MUST
CONSIDER WHEN REVIEWING A
PROPOSAL TRADITIONALLY CONSIDER
THE FOLLOWING INFORMATION. IF IT
IS DETERMINED THAT SUCH
INFORMATION IS RELEVANT TO THE
AREA THAT IS THE SUBJECT OF THE
PROPOSAL.
FIRST INFORMATION CONTAINED IN
THE LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN.
INFORMATION CONTAINED IN THE
SAFETY ELEMENT OF THE GENERAL
PLANNED. AND ANY MAPS THAT
IDENTIFY LAND AS A VERY HIGH
FIRE HOUSE OUR SEVERITY ZONE.
OR MAPS THAT IDENTIFIED LANDED
TERM TO BE IN THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
ALLOWS HEALTH AGENCY IT HEALTH
EMERGENCIES TO BE DECLARED EVERY
THIRTY DAYS INSTEAD OF EVERY
FOURTEEN DAYS.
REQUIRES A LEGISLATIVE BODY OF A
COUNTY TO TRANSMIT A COPY OF THE
FINDINGS FROM THE STATE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
UPON APPROVAL OF A TENTATIVE MAP
OR A PARCEL MAP WHICH A
TENTATIVE MAP WAS NOT REQUIRED
FOR AN AREA LOCATED IN AN SR A
OR A ZONE.
ALLOWS OF THAT THE LOSS OF
HOUSING UNITS DURING THE
GOVERNOR DECLARED EMERGENCY THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN REBUILT OR REPLACE
TO BE ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION PROCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SO SECOND.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THERE PARTICULARLY ENAMORED WITH
TWO PIECES OF THE BILL. THE
FIRST BEING THE CHANGE FROM
EVERY TWO WEEKS EVERY THIRTY
DAYS FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. IN THE VERY BEGINNING
OF THE RECOVERY OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HOW TO RECONVENE
JUST FOR THAT PURPOSE AND IT
WAS.
ON THE JUST THERE SO MUCH OTHER
REAL WORK TO DO THAT THEY WERE A
BIT FRUSTRATED BY THAT. THAT
REQUIREMENTS OF THE GOVERNOR
ACTUALLY INCLUDED IN HIS.
DECLARATION HE ALLOWED THAT HE
WAVED IT FOR JUST THIS ONE
EMERGENCY BUT THIS THIS CHANGE
IN THE LAW WILL MAKE IT. BETTER
FOR ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS JUST
TRYING TO HELP THEIR
CONSTITUENTS RECOVER IN THE
FUTURE AND SECONDLY THE PIECE
ABOUT THE ARENA.
WITH THE NUMBER OF HOMES
DESTROYED AND THE NORTH BAY
THERE'S JUST NO WAY THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO JUST EVEN
REBUILD THE FOLKS HOMES THAT
WERE LOST. LET ALONE MEET RENO
TARGETS AND THE NEXT CYCLE AND
ANYWAY THAT WOULD JUST SORT OF
BE LAUGHABLE SO WE APPRECIATE
THOSE TWO CHANGES BEEN
INCORPORATED AND.
YOU KNOW IT'S A TRAGEDY THAT
THAT HAPPENED BUT WE APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATURE STEPPING UP AND
MAKING IT BUT EASIER TO RECOVER
IN THE FUTURE MUST PRIVATELY
THINKING.
THANK YOU OTHER OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OUT WE HAVE A MOTION MISSILES
ARE BETTER WHEN I'M BORED OKAY.
COMMITTEE COMMENTS.
TIONS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD HAVING.
TO DEAL WITH THE LILAC FIRE IN
MY DISTRICT.
IT'S YOU KNOW AND SEVERAL
TERRIBLE. TRAGEDIES FIRES IN THE
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF DECADES.
WE LEARN EVERY TIME WE HAVE
THESE EVENTS SO WHERE BUILDING
UPON THAT AND MAKING IT BETTER
EACH TIME SO. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AND WITH THAT.
CLOSING COMMENTS I SIMPLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WHERE CURRY
AYE AGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO.
COOLEY COOLEY AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
STONE.
STONE I'VE OF CO. VOEPEL I.
BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO.
THE ITEM TO A TWENTY NINETEEN IS
AND.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AS I AM SURE YOU ALL RECALL LAST
YEAR THIS COMMITTEE HELD AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS.
THIS HEARING HIGHLIGHTED A
NUMBER OF HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
THAT ARE DOING GREAT WORK.
I FULLY RECOGNIZE APPLAUD THESE
DISTRICTS IN FULLY SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO ENCOURAGE THEIR
SISTER DISTRICTS TO ADOPT THEIR
BEST PRACTICES.
HOWEVER OVERSIGHT HEARING ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PRACTICES OF SOME HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS.
THIS LED TO THE COMMITTEE BILL
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHT.
AS REFRESHER AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT ESTABLISHED A VERY BASIC
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
REQUIRED HEALTHCARE JET
DISTRICTS TO DO JUST A FEW
SIMPLE THINGS.
ADOPT AN ANNUAL BUDGET ESTABLISH
AN INTERNET WEBSITE ADOPT ANNUAL
POLICIES FOR GRANT FUNDING.
I CONSIDERED AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
WHAT AS A STARTING POINT WAS
CLEAR ABOUT THE APPROACH LAST
YEAR.
WE DELIBERATELY KEPT THE BILL
AND ITS REQUIREMENTS NARROW HE
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF TAKING
SMALL STEPS IN THE STABLE SHE
RUDIMENTARY TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES FOR
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS.
THE WEBSITE REQUIREMENTS FOR
VERY LIMITED THE ONLY PIECE OF
INFORMATION HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS REQUIRED TO POST WAS
CONTACT INFORMATION FOR THE
DISTRICT.
HOWEVER WE ALSO ENCOURAGED
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS TO POST
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
ALSO VERY BUSY BASIC INFORMATION
INCLUDING THEIR ADOPTED BUDGETS.
A LIST OF CURRENT BOARD MEMBERS
INFORMATION REGARDING PUBLIC
MEETINGS THAT EXISTING LAW
ALREADY REQUIRES OF HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS.
RECIPIENTS OF GRANT FUNDING
PROVIDED BY THE DISTRICT. AUDITS
IN FINANCE REPORTS THAT EXISTING
LAW ALREADY REQUIRES FOR HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS.
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR GRANT
POLICIES ARE ALSO LIMITED TO
ONLY TWO ITEMS REQUIRED THE
AWARDING OF GRANTS TO CONTAIN A
LINK TO HEALTH CARE. AND THE
MISSION OF THE DISTRICT.
WE ALSO REQUIRED A PROCESS FOR
EACH DISTRICT TO ENSURE GRANT
FUNDING IS SPENT CONSISTENTLY
WITH THE GRANT APPLICATION AND
THE MISSION OF THE DISTRICT.
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE STUFF.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY IS AB
TWENTY NINETEEN THE BILLS ON THE
WORK BEGUN LAST YEAR WITH A B..
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WE WANT
TO KEEP THE MOMENTUM GOING. BUT
WITH INCREMENTAL CHANGES.
AB TWENTY NINETEEN WOULD REQUIRE
RATHER THAN ALLOW HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS TO POST ON THEIR
WEBSITES THE LIST OF INFORMATION
WE ASK THEM TO CONSIDER LAST
YEAR. BUDGETS BOARD MEMBERS
FINANCE REPORTS AND SO FORTH.
AB TWENTY NINETEEN ALSO REQUIRES
DISTRICTS TO POST A GRANT
POLICIES ONLINE.
TO REITERATE ALL OF THESE ITEMS
ARE ALREADY REQUIRED TO REFER TO
PRODUCED UNDER CURRENT LAW.
IN ADDITION THE BILL INCLUDES
MEASURES TO MAKE IT EASY FOR
DISTRICT OPPOSED AUDITS AND
REPORTS ON THE OTHER AGENCIES
PRODUCE A OR RECEIVE.
L. BY ALLOWING A LINK TO THOSE
AGENCIES WEBSITES.
AB TWENTY NINETEEN ALSO FLESHES
OUT THE REQUIREMENTS FOR HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS GRANT POLICIES.
IT REQUIRES THESE POLICIES TO
INCLUDE.
REQUIREMENTS THE GRANT RECIPIENT
MUST MEET AND A PROCESS FOR
PROVIDING ACCEPTING AND
REVIEWING GRANT APPLICATIONS.
THE DISTRICTS PLAN FOR
DISTRIBUTING THE GRANT FUNDS FOR
EACH FISCAL YEAR.
A PROHIBITION AGAINST INDIVIDUAL
MEETINGS REGARDING GRANT
APPLICATIONS BETWEEN THE GRANT
APPLICANT AND A DISTRICT BOARD
MEMBER. OFFICER OR STAFF OUTSIDE
THE DISTRICTS ESTABLISH GRANT
AWARDS PROCESS.
AB TWENTY NINETEEN ALL THREE CAR
REQUIRES HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL GUIDELINES
ON SPECIFIC ISSUES IN THE GRANT
POLICIES.
AND GIVES THEM AN EXTRA YEAR TO
DO THIS.
BY JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY.
THE GOAL IS TO ENSURE THE
DISTRICTS CONSIDER. DELIBERATELY
WHAT THE IT THEIR GUIDELINES
WILL BE IN AWARDING GRANTS AND
TO MAKE THOSE GUIDELINES
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
THE BILL REQUIRES DISTRICTS TO
DETERMINE WHAT THEIR GUIDELINES
WILL BE ON THE FOLLOWING ISSUES.
AWARDING GRANTS TO UNDERSERVED
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES.
AWARDING GRANTS TO MULTIPLE
RECIPIENTS
EVALUATING THE FINANCIAL NEEDS
OF GRANT APPLICANTS.
CONSIDERING WHETHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO NOT
PROVIDE DIRECT PATIENT CARE
PROGRAMS WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
GRANT FUNDING.
FUNDING LIMITATIONS FOR PRIOR
GRANT RECIPIENTS.
CONSIDERING SPONSORSHIPS OF
CHARITABLE EVENTS.
FUNDING OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCIES.
AWARDING GRANTS TO AND LIMITING
FUNDS FOR FOUNDATIONS THAT ARE
SPONSORED OR CONTROLLED BY OR
ASSOCIATED WITH A SEPARATE GRANT
RECIPIENTS.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON GRANT POLICIES
BECAUSE APPROXIMATE TWENTY
PERCENT OF HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
ENGAGED IN NO OTHER ACTIVITY
OUTSIDE OF AWARDING GRANTS.
WE BELIEVE THIS GRANT POLICIES
SHOULD BE ROBUST AND EASILY
ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC.
WE'VE HEARD SOME CONCERNS FROM
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS AND THE.
AND THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION REGARDING
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL.
AND WE ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH
THEM GOING FORWARD.
OUR GOAL IS NOT TO UP OUR GOAL
IS NOT TO OVERWHELM HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS.
IT IS TO PROMPT THEM TO CONTINUE
IMPROVING THEIR TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY POLICIES AND
PRACTICES.
AB TWENTY NINETEEN ALSO REQUIRES
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS TO NOTIFY
THEIR RESPECTIVE LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSIONS LEFT GOES
WHEN FILING FOR BANKRUPTCY. IN
RESPONSE TO THE NUMBER OF HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
DECLARED BANKRUPTCY.
FINALLY TWENTY NINETEEN REQUIRES
TWENTY PERCENT SET ASIDE FOR
AFFORDABLE UNITS WHEN HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS ARE. USE DESIGN
BUILD AND CONSTRUCT HOUSING.
WE HAVE DISCUSSED THIS PROVISION
WITH BEACH CITIES HELP DISTRICT
AND WILL WORK WITH THEM TO
ENSURE THIS PROVISION DOES NOT
APPLY TO DEMENTIA CARE
FACILITIES. ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITIES OR OTHER HOUSING THAT
INCLUDES A DIRECT HEALTH CARE
COMPONENT.
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO BUILD
ON THE FOUNDATION FROM WE
STARTED ON AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT. AND TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS TO OCCUR
IN THE LEGISLATURE. REGARDING
THE BROAD POWERS WE HAVE GRANTED
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS.
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THEY FACE
AND HOW TO BEGIN ADDRESSING
THESE CHALLENGES I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS EFFORT.
OTHER OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SHARE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JIM E. WORK
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION. OF THIS
IS A BILL THAT PROVIDE.
EASIER ACCESS TO INFORMATION
FOR JOURNALISTS AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC.
IT ALLOWS THEM TO MORE EASILY
ANALYZE PRECIPITATED DATA.
AND ARMED WITH THAT INFORMATION
ALLOWS THEM TO MORE MEANINGFULLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THE
BILL.
AND KILL OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BUT DAVID KEENE TANA WITH BEACH
CITIES HEALTH DISTRICT.
AS THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
SUPPORT IF AMENDED.
BUT AS THE AUTHOR ALLUDED TO WE
ARE WE'RE JUST ABOUT THERE WERE
PRETTY SURE THAT ARE ISSUE WILL
GO AWAY. BEFORE THE.
ITEM EVEN HITS
THE PREPARATIONS OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE PAMELA MILLER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LAUGHED BECAUSE.
WE HAVE NOT TAKEN A POSITION ON
THE BILL THE MAJORITY OF THE
BILL DOES NOT RELATE TO LAUGH
BECAUSE HOWEVER THE ONE
PROVISION. OF THIRTY TO ONE
FORTY WHICH REQUIRES THE HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS TO NOTIFY LAUGH
CHO WHEN THEY FILE FOR
BANKRUPTCY. WE DO SUPPORT THAT
PROVISION THINK YOU.
OKAY A.
IF OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M JEANNE
HURST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO STICKLER FIVE BUT
WITH CONCERNS. I'M THAT I'M
WE'VE ALREADY SHARED WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
.
I HAD THAT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
IS FULLY COMMITTED TO
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS AND
ACTUALLY IT'S BEEN WORKING
REALLY HARD TO.
HELP HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE IMPROVE IN
THOSE AREAS.
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
SPECIFIC PROVISIONS OF THE
MEASURE BUT TODAY ARE BORED I'M
ASKED TO FORM A SMALL GROUP OF.
MEMBERS TO WORK ON SPECIFIC.
AMENDMENTS THAT WE PLAN TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF ON
TO HELP US ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
AND HOPEFULLY WE. CAN GET TO A
PLACE WHERE WE ALL FEEL
COMFORTABLE AND CAN MOVE FORWARD
I'M SO WE APPRECIATE THAT
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
FUSSING THEN A COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISTER BONE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING US THIS
BILL I HAVE A SPECIFIC CONCERN
ABOUT THE DESIGN BUILD PROVISION
THAT REQUIRES.
TWENTY PERCENT OF RESIDENTIAL
UNITS TO BE AFFORDABLE I'M NOT
OFFENDED.
BUT IN THE LEAST BY THE
PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AS PART OF A.
OF LARGER HOUSING PROJECT AND
IN FACT HAVE FTA. HAD THE
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING BILLS OF MY
OWN.
BUT I AM. CONCERNED THAT THE
MANDATE OF TWENTY PERCENT. IS
NOT ONE THAT IS ALWAYS GOING TO
PENCIL OUT AND WHAT WE'VE FOUND
IN VARIOUS CITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IS THAT.
A PERCENTAGE IN ONE COMMUNITY
DOESN'T WORK AND ANOTHER.
SO I I'D LIKE TO ENCOURAGE YOU
AS YOU HAVE DISCUSSIONS GOING
FORWARD ON THIS BILL THAT YOU
CONSIDER BUILDING IN SOME
FLEXIBILITY. TO THAT
INCLUSIONARY REQUIREMENT.
AYE SO THAT WE ACTUALLY SEE THE
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING THAT I
THINK THAT YOU'RE ENVISIONING.
BOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN THE
TWENTY PERCENT AFFORDABLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
PACKAGE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED LAST YEAR AND I AGREE
WITH YOU THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
DISTANCE FLEXIBILITY SO WILL BE
WILLING TO WORK ON THAT. THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE. OF WE NEED A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND. A
CLOSING COMMENTS.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO COMMENT THAT
YOU KNOW.
AS WE WERE ALL. PLACED HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE WE PROMISED
OVERSIGHT. AND THIS IS ONE OF
THE THINGS WE DID SIDES TALK
ABOUT IS LIKE HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE LEGISLATION GOES GETS
THROUGH IS A GOING IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED. AND SO BASED ON
THAT I JUST WANT TO SAY I
APPRECIATE.
YOU.
I RESPECTFULLY GETTING AN AYE
VOTE FROM ALL OF YOU TODAY THANK
YOU.
ON THE OTHER CHAIR HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS.
.
AND I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MY MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR CURRY. AYE
AGUIAR CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NOT VOTING BLOOM.BLOOM
AYE COVER AERO. CAVIAR AYE
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY KNOWS STONE. STONE I'VE
VOEPEL O..
NO PALE NO.
AND THE VOTE OF SIXTY TWO VILLA
SOUTH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER THREE A.
B. TWENTY SIXTY THREE.
WHAT WE'RE BACK?
ONCE AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON.
THE RESIDENTIAL PACE ASSESSMENTS
ARE AMONG. OUR AMONG THE FASTEST
GROWING TYPES OF PROPERTY
SECURED FINANCING IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH CUMULATIVE AT US
ASSESSMENTS
GROWING FROM A LEAST AT LEAST
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION TO.
THEM TO THOUSAND FOURTEEN TO
OVER TWO POINT SIX BILLION AT
THE END OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
THIS IS A GOOD PROGRAM.
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE BETTER BY
PROTECTING OUR CONSUMERS.
RECENT REPORTS INDICATE THAT
DEFAULT RATES ARE RISING AS THE
PACE INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO GROW
DEFAULTING ON A PACE ASSESSMENT
CAN LEAD TO A FOCAL PRO.
FORECLOSURE.
ARE A COUNTY TAX SAILED THE
CAUSES PROPERTY OWNERS TO LOSE
THEIR HOMES.
WELL MAJOR STRIDES HAVE BEEN
TAKEN TO SECURE STATEWIDE
OVERSIGHT BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT AND ENHANCE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN BOTH SP
TWO FORTY TWO. AND AB TWELVE AB
FOUR LAST YEAR MORE WORK NEEDS
TO BE DONE.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR WAS
HASTILY DRAFTED ON THE FINAL
NIGHT OF SESSION AND CONTAINED
IN NUMEROUS PROVISIONS THAT
MEMBERS OF BOTH HOUSES AGREED
THAT WOULD NEED TO BE CLEANED
UP.
WHEN AB TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR WAS
HEARD BY THE SAID IN THE
ASSEMBLY POLICY COMMITTEES ON
THE FINAL NIGHT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN LEGISLATIVE YEAR.
THERE IS SO MUCH CONSENSUS.
THERE WAS SO MUCH CONSENSUS ON
THE NEED FOR SUCH CLEAN UP THAT
A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
COMMITTED TO SUCH AN EFFORT.
THE LETTER SPECIFICALLY SAID.
I COMMIT TO WORKING SUPPORTING
ONLY TO PASS A MEASURE. ON THAT
THE ISSUE OF UNDERWRITING RAISED
ON PAGE TEN OF THE ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
AB TWENTY SIXTY THREE WILL MAKE
CERTAIN THAT A HOMEOWNERS A
BUILDING TO PAY THE ASSESSMENT
IS FULLY VERIFIED BEFORE SIGNING
AN ASSESSMENT OR HOME
IMPROVEMENT CONTRACT. IN BEFORE
WORK ON THE IMPROVEMENT ACTUALLY
BEGINS.
THE TIMING OF THE VERIFICATION
IS CRUCIAL TO DISK TO DISK
CREASING THE NUMBER OF DEFAULTS
AND REDUCING THE RISK.
PROPERTY OWNERS LOSING THEIR
HOMES.
ADDITIONALLY IT WITH THE RECENT
FIRES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
HOMEOWNERS WHOSE HOMES REDUCE
DESTROYED AND HAVE PACE
ASSESSMENTS FOR HOME
IMPROVEMENTS MAY NOT CARRY
SUFFICIENT PROPERTY INSURANCE TO
COVER THE FULL VALUE OF THE
HOME.
AND THE SUBSEQUENT IMPROVEMENT.
THESE RESIDENTS MAY BE REQUIRED
TO CONTINUE PAYING FOR
IMPROVEMENT THAT NO LONGER
EXISTS.
THIS BILL AIMS TO RECTIFY THAT
SITUATION BY REQUIRING PACE
ADMINISTRATORS TO COMMUNICATE TO
THE PROPERTY OWNER. THAT THEY
SHOULD CONTACT THEIR INSURANCE
PROVIDER TO DETERMINE THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF INSURANCE
TO COVER THEIR PROPERTY. AND THE
IMPROVEMENTS
AB TWENTY SIXTY THREE PROMOTES
ACCOUNTABILITY. FERVENT
OVERSIGHT AND RESPONSIBLE
LENDING WHILE ENSURING THAT THE
PACE PROGRAM AND ITS PRINCIPLES
OF ENERGY AND WATER EFFICIENCY
CAN BE MAXIMIZED FOR THE YEARS
TO COME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
WITNESSES.
I'VE GOTTEN IN AGAIN KAREN
LAYING HERE AYE NOW GOV OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURERS AND TAX COLLECTORS.
WE ACTUALLY COLLECT THE PEACE
ASSESSMENTS TWICE A YEAR AND WE
MET THEM TO THE ADMINISTRATORS
OR. GENERALLY THE FIRST I
NOTICED SOMETIMES THAT FOLKS
HAVE THAT THEY ACTUALLY ARE
ENOUGH TO PAY BACK FOR THEIR
PROPERTY TAX BILL. AND IF YOU
CAN'T PAY YOUR PROPERTY TAXES
EVENTUALLY LOSE YOUR HOME SO
IT'S VERY CRITICAL TO THE
TREASURE TAX LIKE OURS THAT
FOLKS COMPLETELY AND FULLY
UNDERSTAND OBLIGATIONS. THAT
THEY'RE TAKING ON BUT THE PACE
ASSESSMENT AND THAT THEY CAN'T
AFFORD. THE LEAN SO. ALL OF LAST
YEAR AND BEFORE THAT AS WELL
WE'VE BEEN AYE SUPPORTING
LEGISLATION TO REQUIRE BETTER
UNDERWRITING STANDARDS.
AND THIS BILL MOVES FAT
SIGNIFICANTLY FORWARD IF YOU
LOOK AT THE CHART ON. PAGE SIX
OF YOUR ANALYSES. THERE'S THE
CART AND A HORSE THEY'RE NOT IN
THE RIGHT ORDER IN CURRENT LAW.
AYE YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO. USE
IT IT'S SECURED BY YOUR HOME YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO PAY FOR IT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO USE YOUR HOME. A
SORT OF THE SECURITY FOR THE
LEAD RIGHT NOW THAT IS IN
REVERSE AND WORK COULD START ON
YOUR HOME BEFORE. THE
ADMINISTRATOR HAS FULLY VERIFIED
YOUR ABILITY TO PAY FOR THAT
WORK SO THIS BILL STRAIGHTEN
THAT OUT. AND SECONDLY I GOING
BACK THE WILDFIRES ABOUT EIGHTY
HOMES IN CINEMA COUNTY ALONE
BURN TO THE GROUND THAT HAD
PIECED ASSESSMENTS ON THEN. WE
DO NOT KNOW IF THEY HAD ENOUGH
INSURANCE TO COVER THEIR HOME
AND THEIR PEACE ASSESSMENT. THE
PACE ASSESSMENT STAYS ON THERE
FOR TWENTY YEARS EVEN IF IT WAS
THE FIRST EVER PACE ASSESSMENT
AND YOU HAD A SOLAR ARRAY WORTH
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IT'S
GOING TO STAY THERE FOR TWENTY
YEARS. AND ONE THING WE KEEP
HEARING ABOUT IS THE HOMEOWNERS
WERE. IN MANY CASES GROSSLY
UNDERINSURED JUST FOR THEIR
DWELLING LET ALONG THE PEACE
IMPROVEMENTS SO OF THOSE TWO
SAFEGUARDS AND THE SPELL.
AMONGST EVERYTHING ELSE THAT IN
OUR REVIEW THEM THIS CRITICAL
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS WE ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THEY THINK YOU.
MY NAME IS TED MERMAN I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION WE
SUPPORT.
AB TWENTY SIXTY THREE.
NOT LEAST FOR ITS PUTTING THE
CART BEFORE THE HORSE.
I.
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT A HOMERS
ABILITIES TO PAY THE ASSESSMENT
IS REVIEWED BEFORE SHE SIGNS AND
ASSESSMENT.
OR HOME IMPROVEMENT CONTRACT IS
ESSENTIAL THE SAME THAT YOU DO
SO BEFORE THAT THAT THE THAT
ASSESSMENT HAPPENED BEFORE WORK
ON THE IMPROVEMENT ACTUALLY
BEGINS.
I THINK. AN ABILITY TO PAY
ANALYSIS REALLY DOESN'T HAVE A
LOT OF VALUE TO A CONSUMER
UNLESS IT HAPPENS BEFORE THAT
CONSUMER COMMIT YOURSELF. TO THE
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS AS COMMON
SENSE IT'S STANDARD PRACTICE IN
THE LENDING INDUSTRY AYE AND WE
BELIEVE IN ADDITION THAT THIS
ANALYSIS SHOULD BE FULLY
VERIFIED AND NOT JUST LEFT UP TO
THE PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS COULD
FAITH.
THE OTHER CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
IN THIS BILL REGARDING DB O.
OVERSIGHT RECORD KEEPING
REQUIREMENTS AND THE METHOD OF
DETERMINING AND PAYING THE.
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ABILITY TO
PAY AN ACTUAL COST ARE ALSO
ESSENTIAL.
FOR THOSE REASONS MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE I CLICK SUPPORTS
THE BILL IN.
ASKS WHEN I VOTE.
MADAM VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
ACCORDING JOHNSON OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
ALSO IN SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THE
UNDERWRITING PROVISIONS AND THE.
INSURANCE PROVISIONS I'M AT
THAT THE UNDER INSURANCE IS
GOING TO BE A HUGE ISSUE WITH
THE REBUILDING AND THAT ON TOP
OF THE FACT THAT THEY NOW HAVE A
PIECE.
MEAN THAT THEY CAN'T PAY OFF ON
WITHOUT INSURANCE IS AN HORRIFIC
AND SO WE ARE I AM PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL ON OUR DRIVE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SUZANNE MARTIN DE WITH CONSUMERS
UNION ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CHRIS ROGERS I'M WITH WHITE
GREEN ENERGY FIND. WHY GREEN IS
ONE OF THE LARGEST RESIDENTIAL
COMMERCIAL AND MULTI FAMILY PACE
FINANCING PROVIDERS IN THE
NATION?
FOR CONTEXT WE'VE COMPLETED
ABOUT FORTY ONE THOUSAND
PROJECTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
CREATING AND SUSTAINING ABOUT
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND JOBS.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF PACE WE'VE
BEEN AT THE TABLE WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH. THIS BODY
AT TO ENSURE THAT WE CREATE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
THAT ARE THE STRICTEST FOR PACE
FINANCING IN THE NATION. THIS
GROUP HAS SEEN OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY THREE.
S. B. TWO FORTY TWO THAT AS YOU
HEARD LAST YEAR ALSO A. B.
EIGHTEEN EXIT BE TWELVE EIGHTY
FOUR YOU'VE HELPED PASS IT RIGHT
IT. AND PUT IT INTO LAW.
WE HAVE MOVED FROM HAVING A
LOCAL OVERSIGHT OF PACE
TO NOW HAVING A REGULATORY
APPARATUS THAT THE STATE BY
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT. WE AS AN INDUSTRY ARE
COMMITTED TO MEETING THE PRIMARY
GOALS SET FORTH BY THIS BODY.
NOT JUST TO ENSURE THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS BUT ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE BROUGHT
ACCESSIBILITY TO AFFORDABLE
FINANCING THAT WILL HELP
HOMEOWNERS HOME OWNERS. BE A
PART OF ACHIEVING THE STATE'S
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE ACTION GOALS.
WHAT WE ARE RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR TODAY IS TO CONSIDER FURTHER
REFINEMENTS TO AB TWENTY SIXTY
THREE THAT WILL ADDRESS
NECESSARY TECHNICAL CHANGES
WHILE HOLDING OFF ON SUBSTANTIVE
SHIPS? AND PASTE POLICY UNTIL AT
A MINIMUM WE HAVE COMPLETED
IMPLEMENTING THE LEGISLATION
THAT WAS PASSED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
THEN THE RULES THAT ARE COMING
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT ANY DAY.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
MOVE THE TIMING OF THE ABILITY
TO PAY DETERMINATION. AND IF AB
TWENTY SIXTY THREE WAS ENACTED
AS IT'S WRITTEN PACE
ADMINISTRATORS WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO MAKE THAT DETERMINATION
BEFORE THE EXECUTION OF THE HOME
IMPROVEMENT CONTRACT. THAT'S NOT
A TECHNICAL CHANGE FOR PACE
ADMINISTRATORS THAT TREATS PAYS
AS A MORTGAGE PRODUCT WHICH TO
THIS BODY HAS REAFFIRMED TIME
AND TIME AGAIN IT IS NOT. PACE
IS A UNIQUE ALTERNATIVE SOURCE
OF CONSUMER FINANCING.
IN DELIBERATIONS LAST YEAR WE
TOOK GREAT PAINS.
YEAH AS A STAKEHOLDER GROUP TO
DISTINGUISH THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE EXECUTION OF THE
HOME IMPROVEMENT CONTRACT AT THE
RECORDATION OF THE PACE
ASSESSMENT.
UNDER STATE LAW A CONSUMER HAS
THREE DAYS WHERE THEY CAN CANCEL
THE PACE ASSESSMENT AND MAY
CHOOSE AN ALTERNATIVE FORM OF
FINANCING FROM PACE AT THAT
POINT.
CANCELING PACE DOES NOT
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT THE
HOMEOWNER IS NOT READY TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THE HOME IMPROVEMENT
CONTRACT.
IT SHOULD BE CONSIDERED AS A
SEPARATE INDEPENDENT.
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
AND WITH THE COMMITTEE TO REFINE
THIS BILL AND TO REJECT ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES. BUT FOR NOW WE
MUST PERFECT RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND CHAIRMAN
AGUIAR CURRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY MY NAME'S
ART INTO THE ACT AND THE CHIEF
STRATEGY OFFICER RENOVATE
AMERICA.
AND AND RESPECTFULLY WE.
OPPOSE AB A TWENTY SIXTY THREE
UNLESS AMENDED.
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT PACE WE
SPENT A LONG TIME A NUMBER OF.
LOW A LOT OF TIME BEFORE YOU
TALKING ABOUT THAT THE VERVE
REFORMS TO THE PRODUCT.
AND TO THE PUBLIC POLICY OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND AS
YOU'VE.
HAVE HEARD IN TESTIMONY TODAY
THE LEADERSHIP OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
OF CHAIRMAN AGUIAR CURRY AND
OTHERS HAS RESULTED QUITE
FRANKLY AND A NEW PRODUCT.
PACE IS FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
THAN I WAS AND EVEN JUST DAYS
AGO. AND HE WAS JUST SEVENTEEN
DAYS AGO IN FACT THAT THE.
RICK STATUTORY REQUIREMENT
PASSED LAST YEAR TO UNDERWRITE A
HOMEOWNER TO THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY.
WAS PUT INTO EFFECT.
AND THE THEIR PACE
ADMINISTRATORS ARE.
ARE HAVE SUPPORTED THESE MOVES
HAVE SUPPORT OF THE
TRANSFORMATION OF THE PRODUCT.
AND AND WE ARE.
HEARTENED TO WORKING
COLLABORATION WITH POLICY MAKERS
AND STAKEHOLDERS ALIKE TO
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THE PRODUCT.
WE ARE CONCERNED HOWEVER WITH.
THE POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES OF
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE. AND
THAT IT WOULD ACTUALLY UNDERMINE
PACE.
AS A POLICY AND A TOOL FOR
EXPANDING.
ACCESS TO FINANCING FOR THE
IMPROVEMENT OF HOMES TO SAVE
ENERGY AND WATER. AND AND HARM
HOMEOWNERS BY FUNDAMENTALLY ON
BENDING THE UNDERWRITING
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT WERE
CREATED JUST MONTHS AGO THROUGH
AB TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR.
THERE WERE SOME COMMENTARY A
COUPLE MINUTES AGO ABOUT A CART
AND HORSE AND THE ORDER BEING
AND INVERTED. I WOULD JUST.
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT THAT WE ARE
REQUIRED TO UNDERWRITE SEE
SOMEONE'S ABILITY TO PAY UP
FRONT WHEN THEY APPLY FOR.
OF FOR FINANCING WE DO THAT NOW.
AND AND THAT IS THE PROCESS
THAT'S IN PLACE.
AND BUT WHAT AB TWENTY SIXTY
THREE AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED DOES
IS IT INTERVENES AND IN THE
PROCESS AND IN THE MARKETPLACE.
AND I IN A WAY THAT ACTUALLY.
ON DOES SOME OF THE PROTECTIONS
THAT WERE PUT FORTH IN AB TWELVE
EIGHTY FOUR. AND AND AT A TIME
WHEN WE ARE IN FRANKLY.
THE MIDDLE OF TRANSFORMATION
BOTH.
BOTH THROUGH IMPLEMENTING THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS FROM THE
LAST YEAR'S.
AS WELL AS.
GOING THROUGH THE REGULATORY
PROCESS WITH THE DB .
NOW WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE CHAIRWOMAN ON HER BELT
WE SUPPORT.
ROBUSTLY THE.
THE GOALS OF OF FURTHER
IMPROVING THIS PRODUCT AND
DELIVERING IT TO THE MARKET IN
THE.
IN THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE IN
DOING SO ALSO IN A WAY THAT
BALANCES THE INTERESTS OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION WITH
EXPANDING ACCESS TO. AND.
AT AFFORDABLE FINANCING TO
ACCOMPLISH OUR MANY CLIMATE
POLICY GOALS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IT WAS CLIFF STAYTON NAM
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
BRINGING FINANCIAL WHERE ANOTHER
PACE ADMINISTRATOR. ARE ALSO
OPPOSE THE BILL UNLESS AMENDED.
CERTAINLY SHARE THE CHAIRMAN'S
POLICY GOALS OF PROTECTING
CONSUMERS BUT FEEL LIKE.
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED THIS BILL.
HAS SOME ISSUES THAT WE HOPE TO
RESOLVE AND WORKING WITH THE
CHAIR THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JOE LA VIE EACH YEAR ON
BEHALF OF SPRUCE FINANCE WHO'S A
PIECE PROVIDER ACROSS TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. IN CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO A FIFTY STATE LICENSED
LENDER I'M IN OPPOSITION
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF THE TIMING
OF FULL VERIFICATION OF INCOME
PRIOR TO. ASSESSMENT CONTRACT
EXECUTION I'M NOT CONSISTENT
WITH HOW OTHER HOME IMPROVEMENT
FINANCE PRODUCTS WORK AND WE
FEEL THAT. AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
THAT IT PUT SPACE AT OUR
COMPETITORS COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE IN THE MARKET SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. ON THE INTENDED GOAL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MAC CLUB AND SEE
NOW WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORED ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSE FOR THE.
FORCED A REASONS THANK YOU.
SYLVIA SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF
ADVANCE ENERGY ECONOMY ALSO.
REGRETTABLY IN LATE OPPOSITION
THINKING.
THANK YOU. US
SEEING NO OTHER OPPOSITION.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
MISTER VOEPEL.
I LIKE THIS BILL A LOT. IT TO
HELP SOLVE SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
WITH PAYS
I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT THE
SAME COMPANIES FINANCE ANOTHER
PROGRAM CALLED HERO.
AND.
DIDN'T SOME OF THE CITIES OF MY
DISTRICT THE CITIES THAT
APPROVED THE HERO PLAN.
THE. CONTRACTORS WOULD GO DOOR
TO DOOR OR USE MASS MAIL AND
BASICALLY MAKE IT SOUND LIKE IT
WAS A CITY APPROVED PLAN.
AND A LOT OF THE SENIOR CITIZENS
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE. WOULD CALL
ME UP SAY HEY WHAT'S THE STORY
HERE. AND I WOULD TELL I KNOW
THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
MARKETING IT THAT WAY BE VERY
MUCH ON YOUR GUARD. SO THERE ARE
OTHER PROBLEMS WITH HERO AND
PACE THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
FUTURE. THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISS CABALLERO.
ONE IS SECOND WITH WHAT TIME MR
VOEPEL SAID.
.
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD BELT ON.
THE.
CHALLENGES THAT THIS PROGRAM HAS
HAD IS.
IS REALLY BEING ABLE TO.
MARKET TO PEOPLE WHO REALLY
CAN'T AFFORD IT AND PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN SOLD THE
PRODUCT. UP OR JUST DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT AND.
THAT THE ARGUMENT THAT THIS
WOULD PUT.
THE PACE PROGRAM AT A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE IS.
.
IT'S I I'M I'M SORRY BUT IT'S
IT'S IT'S LAUGHABLE.
NO OTHER.
HOME IMPROVEMENT.
.
PROJECT.
GETS TO BE IN FIRST PLACE.
AND GET THE AT INTEREST RATES
THAT ARE AYE DEFAULT WOULD BRING
AND SO THIS IS.
THIS IS A REALLY SPECIALIZED
PRIDE PROJECT THAT.
REALLY PUTS.
PACE PROGRAM IN FRONT OF
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT THE
HOMEOWNER WOULD BE PAYING AND SO
FOR THAT REASON I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THERE SHOULD BE
SOME ANALYSIS AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE AS TO WHETHER THAT
HOMEOWNER CAN REALLY AFFORD.
NOT TO ADD THIS TO THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES IN SUCH A WAY
THAT THEY COULD RISK LOSING
THEIR HOMES SO I THINK IT'S A
GOOD BILL.
SPURRED.
ANY OTHERCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
COMMENTS SO THE.
SIR MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
.
AS I CARE CURRY WHICH I LIKED
CLOSE.
I THANK YOU TODAY FOR LISTEN THE
TESTIMONY ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS
YOU KNOW IT COMES BACK TO THE
NIGHT THAT WE WERE AND THE LAST
NIGHT OF THE SESSION. AND WE
COMMITTED TO WORKING TO PASS A
MEASURE ON THE ISSUE OF
UNDERWRITING THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO DAY WE'VE ADDRESSES.
WE'RE HERE TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMER AND I SEE ARTICLES IN
THE NEWSPAPER CONSISTENTLY OF
SOMEBODY LOSING THEIR HOME BASED
ON THIS FINANCING.
IT CAME TO.
IT'S THE FROSTING ON THE CAKE
THAT SAID REALLY REALLY NEED TO
MOVE ON THIS QUICKER SO AGAIN I
APPRECIATE.
YOUR LISTING AND LISTEN TO BOTH
TESTIMONIES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF.
THE SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EMOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFER TO THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE AGUIAR CURRY. AGUIAR
CURRY AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO COVER EURO AYE
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE STONE STONE IVEL CHO.
PROPEL AYE MISSION.
BUT MOTION IS OUT NINE ZERO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR.
I KNOW.
YOU JUST GOT ON MY POLITICAL.
OKAY.
.
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON
A COUPLE OF BILLS.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
A. B. TWO TWO FIVE EIGHT
CABALLERO.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO TWO.
WALDRON.
.
NO.
CAN'T SEE.
WALDRON NO COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE STONE.
STONE I.
THE BILL IS SIX TO THREE ITSELF.
AND ITEM NUMBER TEN A B. TWO
SEVEN ONE ONE CHEN.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
CABALLERO NOT VOTING TO KNOW.
ALRIGHT SO IT'S FIVE TO TWO.
THE BILL IS UP FIVE TO TWO.
THANK YOU.
STORY AT THE ADD ONS NOW.
THANK YOU DIXIE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY NINE CABALLERO MOTIONS TO
PASS AGUIAR CURRY. AGUIAR CURRY
AYE COOLEY. COOLEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE STONE.
STONE I.
WHEN THIS WEEK.
IT'S REALLY.
UPON HER ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY SEVENTY WIND THE MOTION
IT'S DO PASSED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY TWO MOTIONS TO PASS A
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY EIGHT AGUIAR CURRY MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CABALLERO. CUMPLIR I.
SINCE TWENTY EIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR MOTION IS TO PASS IN
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. AGUIAR CURRY. ADWARE
HURRY I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE A. B. THIRTY
ONE THIRTY ONE VOTE HELL. VOEPEL
NO.
AND FOR ARE CONSENT CALENDAR I.
ITEM THIRTEEN A. B. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN RODRIGUEZ WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE STONE.
STONE I.
MA'AM I DON'T. KNOW.
LORD WILL FOR TO OVER THERE.
THIRTY ONE. THIRTY OR THIRTY ONE
TWELVE.
AND.
ADVENTURE IS A NO.
IS THAT RIGHT.
OPEN ON.
IS EVERYBODY READY YEAH.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR
THE DAY WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WE
WILL HAVE TO LEAVE THE ROLE OF.
THANK YOU WE ARE ADJOURNED